can't believe maneuver hasn't owned it
who decided that what
can't believe maneuver has an o in it
who decided that
i mean yeah i'm still reeling over this
i'm dead i've never seen that i stopped
trying to learn language a long time ago
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash
taste and uh this is this is i'd say a
special one right because it's it's
the last episode you're gonna see in
this studio
um oh chris think that as well oh i
don't know
anyway
we definitely didn't script that bit i'm
your host for today guns and with me are
joey and connor
and uh yeah boys how are you doing oh
we got to be moving out a little a
little sad yeah just a very busy time
right now
it is yeah because we've got so much to
do with the new studio it's like all
right we're going to record one before
we start tearing the studio down
yeah yeah exactly right and we're
probably going to film like a short
little vlog for after dark as well which
will hopefully be up
it'll probably be up before this yeah so
go check it after dark yeah because uh i
mean we are literally moving out
tomorrow after we film this today so
by the time we by the time this comes
out you'll probably this will probably
be like
four three four weeks sunken moving
i'm just dreading having to redo
everything and set everything up
yeah because you know we have we have a
setup that works here and everyone's
like why are you moving why are you
moving you know
but you got to mix it up you know keep
it fresh yeah also you'll see why we
want to move if you watch the after dark
vlog
because we have no [ __ ] space in here
i am glad
that i don't have to like i'm i dread
whenever i'm the host because people
don't know the [ __ ] obstacle course
you have to go around to get to this
host [ __ ] i feel literally bad for every
guest that comes
yeah yeah we do have to like perform
parkour together
a lot of tripping hazards and uh yeah
ladybird nearly uh
tested the limits of ourselves yeah in
multiple ways not just the shelf behind
you but all the wires and stuff
that man was too large in charge for
those wives yeah i can't imagine how the
guest feels having to sit here and
having like
what if you need to go to the toilet
right because because the reason okay
the reason i hate going on flights and
sitting on the window seat is
i hate not being able to access the
toilet under my own will
oh i did i i know now my limits of my
own bladder
so now whenever i'm on a long flight i'm
like i'll seat give me a dial seat
immediately i don't have to look at the
view i've seen
yeah i know what the outside of a plane
looks like i know i know what sky looks
like i don't need to look at sky
i i know what a city looks like from
above i will sacrifice
all right hold up okay this is gonna be
our first topic for fun
listen i i am a firm window seat
fan why why i'll tell you why because
right
what's the biggest downside of being in
the isle gentleman what is it come on
there's got to be one downside because
there is no there [ __ ] that you don't
you don't see one there is one glaring
gigantic
annoying issue and that is [ __ ]
people in the window and middle seat
wanting to get out and and god forbid
they're [ __ ] clumsy as [ __ ] and
they're like oh like [ __ ] falling
over everything and they've got like 10
[ __ ] that they got on their lap they got
like the whole
[ __ ] family buffet and [ __ ] like 10
headphones portable charger it's like
for [ __ ] sake put it in your [ __ ]
bag they're trying to shimmy around
like get that [ __ ] away from me i want
to go in the window because i want to
sleep and i don't want to be disturbed
i but you're okay with disturbing
disturbing yeah because
that just shows like the difference in
mentality because i would rather i'm i'm
fine with being disturbed i'm just like
i'm going to go to the toilet man i know
you need it
it's moisture fine with being disturbed
listen i don't okay i don't know if
everyone else sees it the same way as i
do because i know that i get
annoyed by minor things my house could
burn down and i'll be like well that's
[ __ ] that's really inconvenient that
hasn't it
but if someone moves in the aisle seat
for [ __ ] sake no because for me
there's like there's like a counter
right because i i i know how much i piss
i mean i'm glad that i don't need to
worry when i
how much i piss on trash taste because i
piss a lot on trash taste yeah
but in the confines of an airplane
you are stuck there and you ask to go to
the toilet once
all right that's reasonable right
everyone has everyone knows
everyone needs to go to the toilet yeah
but twice okay that's that's that's kind
of pushing it you know
what if i need to go three times when
everyone's sleeping what if what if that
just happens oh you're more worried
about pissing them off yeah
i'm more worried about this picture
you're only on the isle
right what is the limit before you start
to get annoyed with how many times
people get up to go and pee
it doesn't matter because no matter what
i'm going to be pissing more
yeah these two people combine for me for
me for me i i never get pissed off
because i'm like i get him see that's
i i know the pain that's my i know the
trouble you're in i got your brother
that's my mentality right the isle
people the isle chumps are used to being
annoyed that's my theory right so
i don't really feel bad about disturbing
i'm [ __ ] zen on the all you know
the middle c just lose so yeah i mean
they already knew that they already knew
they lost
the middle c is just the loser's seat no
one ever wants to sit in the middle see
unless i think that you're a [ __ ]
psychopath if you actually choose to
sit in the middle see well this is like
okay well i mean you know in your
the only time i don't give a [ __ ] about
middle c is if we're on like an hour or
two flight i'm like
yeah yeah that's fine literally i watch
one jason statham and i'm there
right but i mean i do care on a 12-hour
flight
but you've already lost at that point
and you should have pre-booked that's
your fault
yeah exactly exactly but do you ever do
that gamble where you're like i want the
whole
road to myself this plane looks just
empty enough where i think i can pull
this off you're like i'm gonna book just
the middle seat in a clean row of three
no i know no that's the i like to live
life on the edge because then
i know that what what sick [ __ ] is gonna
want to sit next to a
a madman that would willingly choose the
ilc in a row of three
that should send dangerous that should
like be like a danger sign
no because what i do is that i i get the
safe seat of just an aisle seat because
i know that no matter what even if that
aisle is full
i get the extra leg room i get immediate
access to the toilet i don't disturb
anybody
and win like like but then the moment i
get on the plane
and i see oh not a lot of people waiting
in this in this waiting
room right now right then then that's
when i go like
so uh how many how many aisles are open
today how many hours can i can i sneak
into one of those and like i just asked
and a lot of the times they're just like
yeah that's when it's that's when it's
empty and also i don't ask i just go
oh okay the moment the plane like the
seat belt things come on i'm like that's
a free aisle that's mine i
i could see other people on the plane i
see their eyes looking at the free seats
i'm like no it's mine
i'm getting everything
get down well that's the other benefit
of being in the aisle right you
immediately just go
but yeah i mean it's rare that i've been
i'm on a plane where it's like
that where there's an aisle there you're
like i'm pretty sure the gamble you're
making is like
it's like [ __ ] gotcha odds i am
talking about when the plane is like
basically like 70 to 80 percent full
right yeah
right because again like i said no one
if you if you're on the booking page of
the plane you get to see the layout as
you do
you're not going to sit next to the guy
who picked willingly in the middle
because that that's a bad sign
i wouldn't do that if i saw someone in
the middle i'm like he's a psychopath
that's a psychopath he wants to
socialize
yeah i'm like no no no no no no i'm not
formed for this
i'm not here to [ __ ] socialize i
don't want to join a cult today i'm sure
i'm sure there'll be some cult some
stuff yeah yeah yeah but then i don't
mind going
okay so okay okay i'll do that gamble if
it doesn't work out
i might just i might go to the like
whoever's next to me like you want to
swap
want to swap you actually yeah sometimes
i'm like listen
i'm going to sleep do you want to swap
and then they're like yeah wait how
easily do you sleep on planes because i
i remember when i was like with great
difficulty
so like for me sleeping on the window
seat is actually
less comfortable than sleeping on the
aisle seat as well because
because for some reason like you but
like mine
you know your nature is you know you can
lean on the on the wall
right yeah but the wall of the plane is
i don't know why it's just tilted at
such an angle where you can never get a
comfortable
leaning on that ball it's
i don't know what engineer designed it
to make planes especially on the
window seats the most uncomfortable
angle to lean your head by yeah that is
true
and it is so weird because i have no
trouble sleeping on cars
cars trains or any other kind of moving
vehicle
i sleep like a [ __ ] baby put me on a
plane and i'm like
insomnia like insomnia speed running
it's just like
well i normally wear a hoodie and a
jacket no matter what the weather yeah
i'll use them as padding yeah because it
also gets [ __ ] cold
because i like i need to be i need my
hair to be at least like a 45 degree
angle right
that's called privilege right no no no
no no no like like like
how does the how does the aisle make
this solution better because i can't
i can't tilt my neck enough that it's
like
it's almost like horizontal here's how i
i kind of go
like the wall is here and the seat is
here i kind of nestled
into this corner yeah because it's kind
of like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
because because like like for me like
i said my head needs to be like at least
a 45 degree angle so
you know not not yet not my entire body
but at least my head you know so it
feels at least like i'm lying down even
though i'm
i wake up i get [ __ ] neck cramps or
whatever like i just
just go business like at that point i am
honestly i have no problem just sleeping
like i put my head down and sleep on my
arms on my lap
i can't do that i could do that i've
attempted to do that as well
and i'm too tall that sounds like a
short personal solution to me
this is why you're lower than six foot
you get you can just the world opens up
to you it's like a [ __ ] origami level
the 511 club over here honestly every
time i go on a plane now i'm just like
damn man i wish i wish i was a bit
shorter i wish i was off the 511 club
oh god how does it feel to be sure oh my
god
well that's the other benefit of being
in the lc right is that you can stick
your legs out and actually stretch you
know you can't
you you do for 10 minutes and the woman
comes over she's like hey put your
[ __ ] legs in oh the cart comes by and
you like your legs it's [ __ ] cool
i'm like [ __ ] up right up against the
seat though yeah like it just slides
pause
i don't know i don't know man jackie
chan
i don't know if i can do this now
because it's been fine like two years
since i've been on a long flight
yeah it's been a while yeah yeah it's
been like two years but i used to
i used to stay up all night working and
then my flight would be at like what
like maybe midday if i was lucky yeah
maybe 8 a.m if i was even luckier yeah
so i'd stay up all night working
and then right before i got on the plane
i would just take like one of those like
over-the-counter
really cheap weak sleeping pills yeah
the uk ones yeah they're super
they're they're not like american
melatonin no no
melatonin is the good [ __ ] yeah that's
like illegal in the years or you need a
prescription to get melatonin oh really
yeah i think the one that you get
from those stores like similar to hay
fever medicine i think
uh like i swear to god that's your sugar
pills it's
so very good it doesn't actually do much
but it's enough to like kind of get your
head going and you're like all right
i'm already sleep deprived i stayed up
all night working yeah and now i'm gonna
go to bed
because like when i would when uh what
was it two and a half years ago maybe
the latin
the last con season i actually did
before pandemic i went
back and forth from america like four
times in one month um
to the uk yeah and the only way i could
do it was by sleeping i just like
i if if i need to sleep on a plane and i
don't have like melatonin or like
sleeping pills
i've never taken melatonin yeah i just
go like just give me like two gin and
tonics just
just down fashion alcohol doesn't work
on me just to make me sleep i don't know
really like
to me i never drink alcohol on planes
because alcohol just
makes the fluids run through my body
faster so i just gotta pee more
so that that's just that just adds an
extra layer of stress for me because i'm
sorry i gotta pee more now i'm on this
plane
i cannot pee i i can hold the pin i
cannot pee
of oh i i can hold the p for like the
whole 12 hours
you're a mad man like i unload before i
get on the plane
i load i fully unleash it and i drink
minimal water on the plane yeah well i'm
pretty sure i'm pretty sure i unload as
much like possibly can i go to p
like five times before i get on the
plane on and like i sit down
immediately as i know probably being
five times forgetting the plane your
bladder already sounds like it's failed
you before you even got to the gate
i'm only peeing like once i don't know
what it is though it's like it's like a
pavlovian effect where like the moment
you hear the doom
of like the seatbelt sign it's like a
[ __ ] i have to pee
every time i mean that's what i can hold
it and i can sleep so i'm like i tell
the people next to me like
if they seem nice if they don't seem
nice i won't say anything because
you could just tell us tell them what i
should be like don't if the food comes
don't work me out
i don't care about you don't wake me up
for anything so you're gonna say
don't worry uh don't worry if you have
to pee because uh i'm i'm all for it man
sometimes if you're in like if you're
asleep and they ask you do you want food
and they think that you're like actually
like
conked out like completely yeah they
might think like oh my god he's like
he's fainted or something or like you
know no i've done i've just
if i'm if you don't wake up if you don't
wake up yeah if i'm on a plane and i'm
asleep while the food
goes past like i've never been woken up
for food oh my god people wake me up so
many times
dude that is i hate that and i'm like do
you know how hard i worked
exactly right i waited two hours to get
to sleep for five [ __ ] minutes so you
could wake me up
this is why i also don't want to sit in
the [ __ ] in the aisle because the
moment i fall asleep
some person could be like excuse me can
i go to the toilet
you literally waited you waited until i
felt fall asleep all right
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] i hate you you're
a scum of the earth
i will watch the moment i see them about
to fall asleep i'm like i'm going to pee
if i'm in the
thing because i want to give you
something yeah and like there's only one
thing that
annoys me more about getting woken up
just just to eat you know on a plane
which i wasn't even hungry in the first
place
and that is babies on a plane i don't
know
man crying babies on a plane just
triggers something in me man i think it
should be legally allowed
cancelling headphones i don't they're a
lifesaver literally the
what are they called dude i i i feel
like i i feel like a baby's cry pierces
any kind of anything dude those sony wx
fourth out whatever the [ __ ] they are
the stupidest name they've ever picked
for them those
amazing noise counting headphones you
won't hear a [ __ ] thing yeah
yeah because i've i don't know i don't i
don't usually use noise cancelling
headphones that might be my problem
because right now i'm just like i think
it should be legally allowed to punch
babies if they cry on a plane like
that's
can we
[Music]
oh my god i never thought i needed
noise-canceling headphones until i had
them and then i can't i literally go
everywhere with them
like you you see me i'm always where you
are yeah i do not go anywhere without my
noise cancel headphones now
i would only use noise cancelling
headphones for the airplane that's
because that's what you think okay what
in what are the like situations it's so
nice on the train
or any form of transport walking around
just getting isolated and hearing your
music and just the music
and if you want you can hear some
background noise it doesn't really
matter dude it's like living
through an amv it's [ __ ] awesome it's
great i want to hear phil defranco when
i'm walking downtown going what's up
beautiful bastards in my ear right in my
it's like
right in my ear all i want to hear is
fill in my i know i feel like i zone out
enough as it is i don't need noise
cancelling headphones
like me i literally just walk in front
of a truck or something i've had noise
cancelling
you learn to adapt you
you take out one sense so you gotta
compensate for it with your other sense
or something
just buy them you'll see you'll see yeah
they're great because i always thought
like expensive headphones are like i
don't need more than 20 bucks or 50
bucks headphones what a scam and then
i'm like i'm such a fool i was so wrong
the whole time the beeps and boobs sound
even better
oh they are amazing yeah i mean i i
changed everything i did used to have
like really really good headphones but
they were just
real happy they were just like a real
hassle
to uh just lug around well i stopped
using them that's right
mine are like they fall in themselves
pretty easy to put a coat pocket or
something
i just use the airpods yeah that's why
that's why i'm i like i like using like
you know earbuds whenever it's daily
life if it's on a plane yeah
i'll bring the headphones yeah no i wear
the headphones everywhere
see like especially this time like i
don't mind the headphones either but
like
this time of year when it gets hot as
[ __ ] yeah i hate
having headphones around i need
something to distract me from the heat
so just blasting the audio add more heat
take one more insulation take one of the
sensors away from me so i can just go to
another world i don't have to [ __ ]
pay attention to japan anymore no i hate
that because i start sweating here like
on my ears and then when i take it off
it's like
well you have a lot of hair though so
that might be why because i don't really
have like that much hair around here so
what i mean that's pretty
i'll be good i'll be good shoot enough
i'll have no hair and then
looking forward to getting sunburned on
your head connor no i'm just going to
become a hat guy
beanie guy you're already starting to
become a hat guy
every time i see you in the summer oh
yeah because i realized that like it
[ __ ] hurts to
not wear a hat it hurts yeah the the sun
hurts so much
i think that's what the biggest thing
that changed me i i was i was walking
today
uh to the train and i was like when did
i just like
hate seeing the sun like when does that
happen cause i remember i didn't mind
being outside
right now i hate the thought of having
the sun on my skin
at all i loved it sounds like the most
british thing i've ever heard honestly i
didn't used to be this way i don't know
what happened
i just now i can't the sun wait can you
literally tan
uh no i just burn right but now i
actually like if i stay in the sun too
long i feel like nauseous real fast
without like a hat or anything yeah i
don't know if that's like a difference
is it just because it's too hot
i think maybe here yeah yeah i think
cause this is just way harder than i'm
using it's also yeah it's also because
the humidity right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah i feel like i feel like
you're just it's more it's not it's not
the sun it's just the heat
because it's both in like england the
sun [ __ ] tickles you you know
it's like i feel like they play off each
other so the sun makes the humidity
worse and humidity makes the sun
yeah absolutely because when the sun's
beaming on you in like la or whatever
yeah it's not too bad obviously i don't
want to stand really it hurts
but i don't know i'm not saying it's
it's great but i mean it's better than
it is in japan just because the humidity
makes it feel ten times worse
i mean i don't know if there's some like
ray [ __ ] like
mimic like you know going in the water
droplets in the edge [ __ ]
the the frogs are making the horse turn
down
i don't know if there's some [ __ ] going
on now [ __ ]
i don't know if there's probably some
someone smarter than me because figured
it out it's honestly i think it's just
like a preference thing right like some
people are like yeah humidity is
whatever and then there are others who
are like oh yeah my
skin is like physically burning i i like
a little bit of humidity
japanese humidity is like way too much
yeah well
last summer i could like only survive by
going around with like a [ __ ] uv
umbrella
i felt like an old that's right i would
just go around like this foldable
umbrella that i would just go around
i'd be like don't talk to me yeah
because i could the first time i saw you
with that i thought
oh i was like are you are you waiting
for me to like say a joke or
like you're taking a piece i realized
it's not enough to protect my head
is this is this a bit it was i it
started like even the hat didn't really
help that much
and i needed to cover like my neck and
like my arms and shoulders so
you need to get those like like visors
i'm one step away from being the old
woman at the supermarket because they
wear like sleeves
like shade sleeves and like a full like
neck thing for the sun shout out to
those of us who've never been sunburned
in our lives
this is this white man problem that i
just don't get i think so
i think i think i'm aging rapidly
imagine imagine sunburning
imagine sunburning oh god imagine being
hurt by
this natural occurring thing that's
existed since the beginning of our
planet i feel like my body didn't age
and then it decided that everyone
everything would just kick into
overdrive and
start aging rapidly from age like 23. i
don't know what happened moving to japan
just made me feel old
i don't know why so now now i literally
the youngest man yeah
my uv umbrella broke it was [ __ ] it
snapped it broke
it broke i don't know how bro did the
sun snap it i don't know
the rays were too heavy i i like to
what broke about how did it break how
long did it break when i you know when
you pull it out because it was one of
the foldable ones so it goes on so i
could fit it like a small bag
yeah um it's just like when i pulled it
out one time it just [ __ ] came off
and i was like oh my god i guess no sun
protection for the day then no so now i
need to buy a new one
i've been looking on amazon but this one
hasn't caught my fancy yet so
i'm very picky is this a fashion
statement or something as well like no
i just i just wanted one that wouldn't
break you know because i i've been burnt
once
twice now from the sun and from the
other then just by uh
more sturdy one surely oh thanks guys
it's an umbrella
it's a [ __ ] doing that it's a [ __ ]
umbrella how wrong can you
how wrong can an umbrella be does it
protect you does it give you shade
that's all he needs to do
surely well i mean you know because why
the [ __ ] you worried about like the
design
well because i already look like a clown
using it i want to at least not make it
too bad and get like
if i get a pink one it's like it looks
pretty bad so i want to try and get like
somewhat stuck nothing wrong with pink
man yeah
i i i could rock it i just don't want to
have to justify why i'm rocking it
people you know what i mean because
[Laughter]
umbrella if that's what you're wondering
that's the most like roundabout way of
saying yes but also
yeah i get a pink umbrella fine i'll
tell you yeah get it yeah i'll get it
get it
for the bit yeah fine fine yeah no one's
going to see it it's literally just
put on the twitter don't worry it's for
the bit my daily life
is a joke we'll put on the twitter don't
worry
subreddit
even partners with japanese artisan
makers to make sure you're getting
authentic
flavors and boku snacks are different
every month and have different themes
hey connor open up the box to show us
what's inside oh i
certainly will jerry as you can see here
this month's theme is
summer fruit soup everything in this box
is fresh and fruity we've got lemon
flavored otonano otsumami
fried rice crackers and peanuts and many
many more the snacks come with an
organic hojicha
tea pairing as well so if you want to
get your hands on snacks that hit
different use our code trashtaste20 to
get 20 off
your own boxy today this offer is only
valid for june and repeat customers will
get a themed box every month
back to the episode [ __ ] you joe script
reading big brain
oh my god yeah so i don't know well in
other news
there's something happening there is
something less light-hearted and more
serious that has happened recently
i was trying to find of like a little
like down time before we get on
i guess we're going straight into it
let's just go straight into depression
so how can we say this boys
one of one of the greatest manga one of
my [ __ ] heroes
one of the one of the greatest manga
artists of all time just passed away
recently and it's kind of old news by
the time this year by the time this
comes out this would be like a month old
news now
um but yeah kentaro miura author of
berserk has passed away
and uh age 54 right yeah age 54 of like
what what did he die of i forgot the
scientific name of it but it's like one
of his like
main arteries in his heart just like
exploded
[ __ ] essentially so basically it's a
heart attack yeah yeah
but yeah it's a [ __ ] horrible way to
die i'll tell you honestly after hearing
about this news
i'm never gonna make fun of a hiatus
ever again yeah honestly
oh no like legit like it's scary man
like
because yeah because you know obviously
no one really knew as to why he was on
hiatus right yeah no
no one knew they they normally don't
usually give reasons they're just like
he's on people are extremely personal
yeah he she's on hiatus just deal with
it kind of yeah
um but yeah apparently i guess i don't
know
was he sick at all or was it just
completely sudden i
don't really i don't know at the time of
recording i haven't read enough about
what happened you know if it was like a
reoccurring health problem or
if it was just a sudden thing but man
like like we all know how much pressure
manga artists get put through
anyway um and how much work they have to
do on a weekly basis
right um i mean it's it's crazy to think
that most of the big
manga artists we know about you know you
know working showing and jump or
whatever
get like two weeks off no less than two
weeks off for a year right it's like
golden week
and then like one extra week yeah as
well yeah i doubt they take it and they
don't really i doubt they take it off as
well it's just one week that where they
are forced to take a break right
i mean i wasn't too familiar with
berserk i'd only watch
the uh the 90s anime i mean that's
familiar enough
which i really enjoyed yeah that's very
good it's great um
but [ __ ] i mean it's kind of sad hearing
like a legend of the industry who's
kind of influenced a lot of things that
we've done yeah because i remember we
were filming
another project when the news broke to
us yeah and it didn't
hit me immediately because i was in like
work mode i was
filming most obviously i was like okay
gotta do this this this and then i got
home
listened to gutz's theme once and he
just played continuously
for like the entire night and i'm just
i'm just sitting there just like [ __ ]
like my soul part of my soul had died
yeah i literally went home and i was
like i'm gonna reread berserk and then
yeah
i feel like everyone did yeah i started
reading it yeah i i couldn't get past
volume one without feeling like
this [ __ ] wave of like [ __ ] yeah
cause like i
i always know that berserk is one of the
greatest manga that has ever been made
and then going back home and realizing
just remembering
everything that was in the story and in
this manga
it just hit even [ __ ] harder because
i just had forgotten
how good it was before i really took the
time to remember
what it had achieved and some of its
greatest moments um if you hadn't read
berserk
there's always a there's always a
perfect time to read berserk because
any time is the perfect time to read
berserk so please read [ __ ] berserk
it's
amazing i mean the manga single-handedly
inspired the dark souls series
i mean it spied a lot it wasn't just
dark souls yeah a lot of things wouldn't
exist
right now if not for berserk oh yeah and
i don't know what i don't know what it
is about berserk but it's literally like
it's literally the one show or not not
even one shirt the one
story or the one manga that seems to be
like no matter how
tough this person is no matter how like
detached they are from the world or
whatever berserk seems to be that one
story that seems to
be able to affect anyone who reads it
yeah because like fundamentally
you know it's like this whole like dark
fantasy thing with these like mythical
creatures and it's bloody gory and
you know epic but like the main themes
mostly are just like
you know one person trying to figure out
what the [ __ ] they want to do in life
yeah and like that's a theme that
literally
anyone can get behind right like i'm
kind of in this world
shit's happening around me i don't
really know what my purpose is in life
yeah i forgot how brutal it was
it's bro i've what again i watched all
the other 90s enemies
yeah holy [ __ ] the 90s obvious brutal as
[ __ ] yeah i was like what the
[ __ ] i was like oh my god it's just like
[ __ ]
it just it just hurts to read yeah it
does
it's so uncomfortable at times yeah and
i think it's incredible because
it is really really [ __ ] brutal there
are some like
like his art obviously we haven't talked
about his audio it's like some of the
best art to ever exist
in the world of manga like some of the
horrific imagery he was managed to
conjure up
and some of like the creature designs
and everything were just
something straight out of a nightmare
you know oh yeah and it was a brutal
show
and it's an action-packed show as well
for his guts is like one of the biggest
badasses
in anime and manga and yet
having said all that the moments that
people
remember are like the really intimate
moments
which is which isn't what you think if
you looked at berserk on a surface level
right you look at berserk you see these
horrific creatures you see
guts with a massive sword tearing [ __ ]
up and you're like yeah
this is a manly man's show and then you
read it and you're just like
[ __ ] crying inside because you know
you see he's
just trying to see guts like get through
his trauma and find his journey and
everything like that it's like
it's the real intimate moments that
always stand out and it's the real
serene moments that always stand out and
i think that's what
that's what really sets berserk apart
from like so many other series where
it's the serene moments juxtaposed
against all like the horrific moments
that make it one of to me like it's one
of my the favor
one of my favorite pieces of fiction
that's ever been made 100
i got reminded of that after remembering
everything that's everything that
berserk did it's like if
the [ __ ] doom guy had like a a wife
and family
and he just went home sometimes you get
reminded you get reminded like oh [ __ ]
this is good
because when you're where you're guys
because i don't know why someone
compared it on twitter and i thought oh
that would be i guess so but then i i
read because i'm like
but it is kind of like you do forget
because sometimes it's like you're
reading it you're like this is like so
doom esque where he's just
literally just beheading horses yeah
yeah yeah and then you're like oh it's
just like dude but then it's like really
sad you're like this isn't like
this is true it's literally that meme
where the girls were like i can't
believe you didn't cry
during titanic do boys even have
feelings and then like this there's just
the boys
crying over the guts theme which was
literally what i was doing
was playing and i was just like crying
in bed just like oh my god
yeah i don't know it's just yeah like
every time i reread it
it's just because you know every time a
new volume came out because there was so
much time in between like the later
volumes
i was like well [ __ ] i guess i have to
read it from scratch again and so i
would keep reading it from scratch over
and over again and it's just one of
those shows where i'm just like
how does this not get like stale yeah
because i probably re i probably read it
like the first 30 volumes probably like
a good like maybe 10 20 times
yeah i'm just like how does this keep
just getting better like how do i keep
finding new things in this
i mean you guys know me i don't [ __ ]
re-watch anything and yeah i refuse to
re-watch but
i even just re-reading the first uh what
was the first art called the
ordination golden age that just
rereading that again i'm like holy [ __ ]
this was so good
yeah like even though i've i've seen
this i i've read it earlier like i tried
to read it again ages ago for some
reason now i'm like
sometimes when i'm bored i just like go
to the eclipse arc and just look at the
art
yeah this is something like this [ __ ]
wait how can one person think of this
yeah i know this is insane and dude was
like 15
as well when you like first came up with
the concept of berserk yeah did you see
like did you see the manga he made
before berserk when he was actually 50.
he was like 15 or 16.
it's better than most modern manga
artists you
not the art skill of a 15 year old
exactly exactly and
like he paired that talent and he he
just kept
improving on it to the point where
literally i i don't know there's only if
like
a few people in the world who i think
can even match you know the talent that
he put into
the panels that he did i mean i saw this
like really interesting interview
uh with him like after you know his
death was announced um where like
apparently one of the big reasons as to
why he was on hiatus was because
he got so infatuated with detail that
it would literally get to the point
where he would zoom in
and like actually edit every [ __ ]
pixel
oh yeah oh my god honestly and like and
sounds like a prisoner to perfect yeah
and
he kept and he kept you know getting
like on hiatus over and over again
and his you know editors would be like
you can't even see this detail on paper
yeah so like just stop and he was just
like no i have to get this right i have
to get this perfect
honestly like some of the panels he's
done belongs in a museum you know
yeah because like i cause the the reason
for that is because i just remembered
like
that night when i went back i just like
went to look at some of the panels and i
just remember staring at them for such a
long time
because you know when you're reading a
story sometimes you know you're you
wanna
you
wanna you wanna see what happens next so
you don't read it you don't appreciate
the arts
um at the moment when you first read it
but
i went back to look at some of the
panels and i just the amount of
work and amount of detail and the amount
of vision that was put into
these panels were [ __ ] amazing and i
did not appreciate it
fully the first time even though i could
like tell these were amazing i didn't
take the time to fully appreciate how
[ __ ] amazing these some of these
panels are because they are
incredible oh hundred percent and they
they you know they
they are just basically the same as any
other painting or any other art i
really wanna you know see if they have
like a berserk art book
of some kind because i would [ __ ]
purchase that in the heartbeat dude
i i i can imagine that they'll probably
end up doing something soon yeah
celebrate the legacy right i hope they
do like open up an exhibit or something
yeah
because that would be absolutely amazing
because if there's one you know one
manga that deserves an exhibit
that deserves that artwork to be
plastered on the wall it's [ __ ]
berserk
yeah it was kind of sad to see that a
lot of people were just like what's
going to happen to the story and it's
like
those aren't fans of bizarre yeah it's
frustrating that like
when i saw the announcement on twitter
saying people being like does this mean
it's not gonna finish it's like like yes
no [ __ ] that's
to me it's just so it's like how about
you just give them a chance to like
grieve before you ask these questions
if anything i'm kind of your answer's
probably gonna be no because there were
a lot of people as well being like oh
but you know
they could probably just get like
mirror's assistance to finish it and
like no no
no no no i would rather it just be where
it is yeah just end it
i'm i'm fine with it being an unfinished
masterpiece you know that's that's fine
that's fine for me
yeah it's berserk was it realistically
ever gonna finish do you think
i mean i don't think i don't think like
not not a single one of like the you
know the kings yeah
were like killed i think only one of
them was i think one of them was yeah
so that was a long there was a long long
way to go yeah we
we were so early in the story and the
pace that the story
was progressing i doubt it would have
finished in our lifetime or you know
i i think it was always going to be
unfinished but i think
berserk's already achieved enough that
it doesn't need to be finished yeah it
was like what i said when we talked
about i think last time we spoke really
manga where i just get to
i often get to a point when reading
margaret i'm like i'm satisfied i
genuinely it would be cool if this ends
nicely but i've read up to a point where
i feel like i'm happy with what i've
been given
yeah and i feel like berserk has
definitely done that yeah
there's been plenty of moments in
berserk that have felt like a resolution
moment yeah like a big resolution moment
even though not every plot detail was
resolved even though not
every loose end was tied up i feel like
it's resolved enough in my heart
to make it like impact me this much
already you know and i think the berserk
you know the journey of guts is already
amazing enough as it is
and some journeys you know some some
journeys don't need to come to an end
on paper you know that's it's i've seen
enough of the journey where
i'm satisfied it's yeah it's just
knowing that he's
he's out there somewhere still yeah
looking for the end right exactly
the biggest [ __ ] sword the fat
[ __ ] sword
yeah and honestly i don't know what else
to say it was just it's
it's a story that has impacted me if
there's anything we can say on this
trash days episode it's please go read
berserk please give it a go pay respect
to the king yeah yeah
honestly honestly he he's he's he's a
[ __ ] coat man
i i hope you know uh if we
find out more about the details of uh
you know what might have caused
his early death um that if it is
something to do with being overworked or
anything that lifestyle that i hope it
does make a change
if it is yeah we don't know that
obviously and you might never know
but if we do find out more details and
it becomes publicly available and we
you know we know that maybe being
overworked yeah yeah i think it would be
good to at least you know kind of put
into the public discussion right because
you know
you know even if you are uh you know you
have because normally with uh heart
problems and this kind of blood stuff
it's normally there is some hereditary
stuff at play yeah
but i mean still at 54 is young like
that yeah
lifestyle would have to have player i
don't exactly i i just want monkeys to
not
not have so much stress on their body
where it fails you know
yeah i don't know i feel bad man it
makes you feel shitty yeah
yeah i mean it's it sucks because i you
know there's there's not really much i
can add to that because
manga artists work a hell of a lot we
know we know they're getting we we
we or not the deadlines that they set
themselves or set on them
yeah too much yeah and it doesn't help
that
fans are so demanding and that for some
[ __ ] reason the first question that
some fans have when an author dies is
what happens to the story yeah it's like
i mean it feels so selfish and it feels
that you know because we we as fans also
have something
where we're selfish and we want yeah
yeah yeah
i don't know like surprisingly from what
i saw there weren't
as many of those
yeah every now and then i saw it i'm
like okay clearly you don't really give
a [ __ ] but yeah
i mean none of that fans are great and
yeah i understand yeah
yeah there were just some of the
insensitive ones yeah
it reminds me of uh but it's like when
there's earthquakes and stuff
right yeah people are always just like
oh the manga it's uh it's delayed
because of an earthquake and it's like
what do you mean like there's people
like people die
like exactly like earthquakes are no
[ __ ] joke
exactly and it's like people that most i
mean you know obviously with this
situation is very sensitive you know and
it was very fresh and
people a lot of people care but i i know
it's especially with like earthquakes
and stuff
people are very quick to be like oh who
gives a [ __ ] it's just an earthquake
it happens all the time yeah yeah and
it's like well i think it plays into the
the overall sentiment of that a lot of
anime fans and manga fans are very
demanding for the stuff that they want
yeah and i feel like we as fans need to
chill out a little bit
yeah they they care about the product
but not so much about the person making
yeah i feel like we're just fans
generally to
chill out about our passion for anime
and manga
i'd say external things happen they
happen it is what it is
remember that some actual person is
making your product yeah you know
whether it be an earthquake or personal
stress they're all valid reasons for
work to be delayed
you know i i just i just want i just
want creators to be able to create the
[ __ ] to the best of you
exactly not have to worry i mean it kind
of reminds me of hope that's not
controversial for me to say
sure everyone can agree on it it's just
more you know we i'm sure
99 percent of people watching this don't
do that it's just that one percent right
it's always that one percent because i
remember this reminds me of like the
game of thrones
thing with joara martin where i remember
like seeing an interview with him and he
was he said that he got annoyed
that some people were worried about his
health not because they were worried
about his health but they're worried if
he would be alive to finish game of
thrones right right and i'm just like
yeah that's pretty [ __ ] up
yeah like fans are saying that to you
aren't they jesus christ yeah and even
if they didn't say it i'm sure he knows
that people are probably thinking yeah
he can read between the lines yeah of
course yeah
i only care about his well-being in
terms of the book like he's being
[ __ ] held hostage by the story
yeah like you know what i mean you can't
[ __ ] do anything if anyone knows the
intention of game of thrones fans it's
the guy who made kevin harris
that's just sad that's just sad i don't
know yeah it's like this makes me sad
for like many reasons you know there's
just so much at play
this does this this is what i mean it's
a sad topic unfortunately it's all about
the respect yeah that's all it is
respect the creators respect the artists
yeah give them some space if they're
feeling sick or need a break yeah moving
on to
light topics though i heard you've been
watching anime recently connor
which is which is a rare which is a rare
feat
i remember i used to do that i know the
anime man
what happened did you guys watch
castlevania yeah the new season
i haven't not season four now but we
haven't talked about castlevania yeah
it's so good
it's so good i mean with how well i mean
i watched up to season three
yeah if there's one anime i have like
kind of caught up to it's castlevania
but like what did you get up to
castlevania uh i got up to season
three so i haven't finished season three
i'm about halfway through season three
yeah yeah i mean but i mean it's just
been for me it's been getting
better and better every season because
it's been going on and i just haven't
had time to binge it yet
so um i don't know man everything about
that anime especially the past season
just blew out the waterfall what's so
good about
it like i feel like everything that was
good in previous seasons was at its best
this season yeah really the story was
the best
the animation was just insane like some
of the fights even though in season
three the fights like the final fight
was so good even season one had some
great animations yeah it just feels like
they've stepped it up
like again like i think one of the
strongest points of castlevania has been
the voice acting
yeah it's voice acting english is
fantastic it's insane
the fact that they have like all the all
the accents
on point none of the accidents feel
silly yeah every single accent that the
characters have it feels genuine every
single british accent
is on point yeah and it's like holy [ __ ]
how do they do this
this never happens how do they get an
actual accent it's like they hired
british actors like i love the fact that
for example that jojo in the dub
like tried to do the accent yeah i wish
they'd got the native
people yeah yeah yeah yeah because like
in jojo part one it's uh johnny and bosh
doing in a
british accent which is yeah it is which
isn't bad but i know
there's no shortage of native english uh
british accents
in that can work in l.a yeah you know
like it it feels like the
voice actors they hide for castlevania's
were just outside of your usual they
were just amazing
yeah they were just like they felt like
general actors that would
act in like a tv series or like a
live-action movie well yeah because they
have like they have such a good
variation of
british accents like they have like the
whole spectrum and each
and they've chosen it like the character
has given the accent based very
specifically on like
where what it would be in the uk like
you're where you were born your wealth
your
socio-economic background it sounds like
it's so stupid but it it fits every
single character
and uh it's just insane because i mean i
i you we can't appreciate it i mean i
could we can't appreciate that in the
japanese one where they might get
regional accents on point
within their own show right sometimes
you get like the subtitles where they're
supposed to be a bit more like
oh sakura yeah yeah yeah yeah a bit
rough i can't really appreciate that
yeah
honestly i've been appreciating japanese
voice acting a lot more recently
yeah um yeah because i've actually i've
actually started to watch
anime without subtitles on right so i'm
like properly
forced wow you are like listen level 100
we right now
oh yeah exactly you're at the final
stage before you graduate
exactly exactly so like the final test
yeah so i'm like trying trying to pick
up more of my japanese and
you know part of the exercise i've been
putting myself through is like
everything i watch now
not subtitled like yeah my enjoyment has
definitely
of anime gone down but it's like this
helps it it helps
so much more it's it's a night and day
watching with subtitles without
subtitles when you don't understand
something that's being said
how do you do you go back and turn
subtitles on or just yeah so normally i
watch anime on crunchyroll or
netflix right so crunchy will also have
the opportunity to
select no subtitles so i can select no
subtitles if there's something that i
really really want to know what they
said i just rewind a bit turn on
subtitles like oh okay that's what he
said right
move on right same thing with netflix as
well yeah um i mean it's it
it turns anime to not just like a
passive watching thing and you're just
like actively
studying material yeah so it is study
material but if you're going to have
study material at least have study
materials
um it's just it's just a different kind
of watching in my eyes but um
since then i like i remember recently
i've been watching nagatoro
without subtitles and i had like my
first
emotional response to watching an anime
and without having subtitles on it was
just
felt it felt nice because i'm just like
oh i i i get what's going on
i'm getting emotional with these
japanese people is this this is this one
yeah
that's exactly what i found it's like oh
i'm i'm feeling some stuff now
japanese people feel i'm not i'm not
reading the subtitles and getting
feelings i'm actually hearing it i'm not
listening to it
yeah i don't know how to quite describe
it because it was it was a new feeling
for me well gone i do the same thing
just with hentai
because they don't have subtitles most
of the time so i i just watched it fair
enough
i feel big brain when i kimochi i'm like
yeah
i got that one i understand that i
i remember going through my japanese
classes and it like i was like uh
so naka means inside and i was like
where have i heard the term
knucker center yeah yeah like inside
well i've
heard oh that's the way i've heard that
before
it's a word you'll hear quite often yeah
that's been many different contexts
yeah that's that's that's the word i've
i've learned from hentai that i can all
i can always go using daily life
it's like the the [ __ ] they're gone
drinking with the [ __ ] coffee
watching subtitles
anime with no subtitles watching
[Music]
yeah the voice acting is just [ __ ]
stellar man i i yeah dude
was like castlevania we would i would
only be watching dubbed out
i mean like do you think it's it played
a massive part to i i assume it's
a big part of it is because it was
dubbed first in english
rather than uh rather than dubbed from
japanese to english
is there a japanese top four i'm pretty
sure be i've never seen it in japanese
i don't know if i'll be able to when you
watch when you watch the dub it's so
goddamn good
it's actually a shame to watch it in any
other language yeah maybe this is how
japanese people feel with something
yeah yeah yeah yeah we'd have a choice
but when we have a choice why would you
you know
you know pick the one thing that is best
right yeah and uh this is definitely one
of those shows where i'm like it's it's
it's not even a competition yeah because
like then obviously it was yeah yeah
because when i watched season one i was
like all right well the default is in
english
yeah because it's an english production
all right i'll watch episode one if this
is
you know voice acting is kind of subpar
then whatever i'll change it yeah but
literally first five minutes i was like
all right english then all right
so this is this is it's fantastic it's
like an anime that is written with kind
of
pretty pretty [ __ ] good american i
would say that's american writers right
so i feel like it's
it's a lot easier for the actors to
because it's like very scripted yeah
because the dialogue is like very witty
and very soft
because you hear the dialogue and it
doesn't feel like anime dialogue it's
so [ __ ] funny it's good it's very
very witty and like facetious
it's just like it it's so rare to find
an anime dub where people actually swear
you know like i can count them on one
hand you know when someone says [ __ ] or
[ __ ] i'm like oh
oh this this stuff's going hard no we're
not in japan anymore
yeah so like hearing hearing it just
like said so naturally
you know like like any like talk to any
other brit or aussie you know it's it's
it's it's something that's like just
ingrained into our speech
if you listen to trash taste you'd
[ __ ] know that um
but it's crazy because it doesn't feel
forced no no yeah because there's a lot
of times where they're like we're gonna
be a little uh explicit just
just to you know be like oh edgy and
everything but in castlevania it's like
yeah i can imagine that yeah
yeah that would totally say that because
like when you hear it in an anime or
like an anime video game because i
remember
the most recent example i can think of
is playing persona five
of dubs and hearing ryuji say [ __ ]
i'm just like eugene wash your mouth sir
you want us a child excuse me when
trevor belmont's like oh for [ __ ] sake
[Applause]
yeah
it's so good dude i [ __ ] like
everything about that like i feel like
even though it gets a lot of good good
you know people say it's very good
i feel like it should be way bigger than
it is it's genuinely like
one of my favorite animes that i've
watched in the past like yeah i
i i really it's really it's really yeah
i can't wait to watch season four fully
and yeah i really need to
you're gonna be like all right okay hold
up i mean i mean for me right now it
doesn't even
feel like an anime you know it's i mean
i mean
it's like it's it's an american
production obviously it's kind of like
we're about to get into that
it feels in the same area as uh avatar
avatar yeah yeah
then i also consider avatar anime i mean
japanese people consider it anime it's
anime like
i didn't know i started anime until i
actually watched all of avatar and i'm
like okay i can see where this argument
never ends
yeah i mean you know with this we're
getting into semantics you know it's
it's
it's whatever because the only thing i
would say
it's fantastic yeah anime or no it's
fantastic i don't give a [ __ ] if you
think it's
it's an anime or not it's just a
fantastic show in general all i was
trying to say is like
i don't think people more people in the
anime community are talking about it's
just because it feels different
yeah yeah yeah yeah let me feel let me
give you an anecdotal story
i was talking to a guy and i asked him i
was like which animes do you like and he
goes
one anime that i watched recently that i
really like this is all japanese like i
recently watched
despicable me 2. it was one of my
favorite animes
of recent and i was like that completely
hold up maybe it made me it made me
realign this whole argument of like
is that is this anime is this not i'm
like listen this guy dead ass
this otaku self-proclaimed attack who
told me despicable me
is a good anime i'm like you know what
why are we arguing
i think it's like i think it's a stupid
argument this is a clown argument
yeah i just killed the argument it's
literally just like the west versus the
west yeah
we made this argument out of nothing
yeah yeah yeah the japanese are like
we're not we're not part of this
it's that simpsons picture where like
the people are surrounding the two
monkeys fighting
that's that's that's the japanese
watching anime fans argue about if this
is anime
i felt like we were like this is how all
religious fighting started right
yeah like the 100th century we just made
we just made an argument out of nothing
because yeah because i mean [ __ ] you
ask a japanese person monster zinc shrek
it's all anime it's just crazy to me
because in japan anime just means
animation i've never just had like
[ __ ] hi i got hit by a truck when he
said despicable me as an animator
it hit me man it hit me real like [ __ ] i
was like this man's built different
saying that right yeah yeah definitely
a different story if you was like the
minions of my waifu like that would have
been different
dude i don't know i don't know why they
obsessed with minions you're obsessed
with indians in japan it's [ __ ]
everywhere i hate it
so we visited joey's new apartment like
last week yeah and uh joey just like
youtube yeah joe's slight detour
it will get back on topic because he was
showing us around he shows us into the
last room
and he's like oh do you guys want a free
gift i was given a free gift from the
moving
the moving department do you guys want
it and we're like sure joey what is it
dead ass just brings out this massive
minions mini fridge
that expects us to take it and he takes
this thing out and we're just looking at
joey being like
joey what do we want to do with this
what what are we going to do with this
and he was like
maybe we can put in the trash taste
studio like joey the trash taste studio
isn't your dumping ground
i have a gift is roughly translated to i
need to get rid of my trash
please please take it i will pay money
because that's i guarantee that's what
they did to joey they were like
joey joe i know i know we're moving all
the stuff for you but here have a free
gift
have a minions mini fridge and they're
like thank god we finally got rid of
that [ __ ]
we're doing you a favor yeah it was
despicable oh my god
i'm break time this episode is sponsored
by vessy you're probably wondering
what is versi well i'm glad to answer
that question it's a comfortable stylish
everyday sneaker that you can wear even
in winter
and the best part about it is that it's
waterproof 100 waterproof shoes
yes and one of the best parts about
vessi is that it is super easy to clean
just toss on some water to it or throw
it in the washing machine and it'll be
brand new
vessy shoes are made via dimetex a dual
climate knit that keeps you cool in the
summer and warm in the winter it doesn't
feel like it should be waterproof
at all and one of the best things about
bessie is that it just looks like an
everyday sneaker so you can just
wear it every single day and i'm very
lazy and only like to have like one pair
of shoes to wear so this is
perfect for me plus vessy shoes are
sustainably made with less material
waste
less water waste and no animal
byproducts so you vegans can enjoy these
as well
also personally and i know the boys can
relate it's rainy season right now in
japan and having a shoe that's
waterproof
is very nice because you don't have to
worry about those goddamn massive
deceptive puddles
getting your shoes and socks worse than
a wet sock so if that sounds interesting
to you
check them out in the description or use
coupon code trash taste to get
25 off your vessy orders look at these
boys
back to the episode speaking of another
anime that has like really
unique voice actors in their cast are
you guys excited for eden
yeah i am actually that is like one that
i saw
i saw little bits and pieces i mean i
knew of it because
yeah a boy care my boy kevin
it's one of those things that wasn't
really on my radar massively it was just
like i know kevin's doing the soundtrack
yeah i'm probably gonna watch so i could
be like great job kevin yeah i wasn't
excited until i saw the clips that we
were shown
which is by the time this podcast comes
out the entire series would have already
been released right
but from the clips that we were shown i
was genuinely like surprised how excited
for this i was i wasn't that excited
before
because i didn't really know what it was
about or how you know good it was going
to be
all i know were the names involved and
what stood out to me was of course
kevin doing the soundtrack so of course
i was always going to watch it but then
the cast list got released and people
like david tennant are in there yeah
neil patrick harris yeah i was like what
is going on
sorry my favorite movie my favorite
yeah it looks really good i mean the
clips we saw as well the animation
looked really [ __ ] good yeah like the
way they matched uh the 3d with the
amazing 2d backgrounds yeah [ __ ]
amazing and again the music we should
[ __ ] bang it
yeah yeah i don't know what else to say
i kind of want to just wait till i watch
it i don't get too hyped for it just in
case okay
but it looked good it's literally out
this week
so yeah i feel like it's gonna be a
seven out of ten for me
really i feel i get that maybe maybe i
get that it depends because it depends
if it's like how it's going to play out
whether it's going to be one long series
because it's a four episode series
so is it going to be only four episodes
or is it gonna be like kind of like a
movie mini series kind of thing that's
what i want to know
i'm hoping it [ __ ] me up you know makes
me very emotional yeah but i have a
feeling i'm gonna play it really safe
it's gonna be quite like a safe story
yeah
i i just i just got that vibe from the
clips we watched
so we'll see i got that i might be
pleasantly surprised
i got that vibes that i was going to
fuel things by the end of it and
yeah the same way i did in the end of
monsters inc you know
i feel like that's what are you talking
about well when they finally you know
they got rid of randall then
they're rascals and they say goodbye to
them very much
is a great match that's a terrible
example
i was just like if there's anything like
monsters saying i'm gonna be happy as
[ __ ] i'm only thinking of great movies
right now but so i don't say the
incredibles i'm like no that's fantastic
like i feel like they've i feel like
these are the movies that have just been
memes so much that you forget
but they're actually bad
point the point is is that i feel like
it i again i want it to be
a super emotional [ __ ] me out but i
just kind of got the feeling it looked
really safe but again yeah
i hope it does yeah i'm just wondering
watch it i'm just wondering because it
was
a netflix adaptation was it cast first
in english or was it dubbed first in
english because
that's what i thought it was an original
story i have a feeling it might have
been cast first in english yeah because
these are some big [ __ ] names to put
behind an anime and you don't normally
see these names unless it's like a
ghibli movie
where disney is dubbing it right so
that's that's what that's what that's
what i'm most interested about because
we talked about
how you know in which order gets dubbed
really does i feel affects
how a dub feels well it depends well
what language is the script written
yeah exactly that's the big question
yeah you can't really
write two scripts simultaneously that
are like one to one
yeah so it's oh especially when it comes
to like english in japan
it's like fundamentally completely
different yeah where the sentence
structure is
opposite at times yeah i think the more
i learned japanese the more i appreciate
what translators have to do
and especially when it comes to
localization a dub by the same time the
more i
understand japanese the more i'm just
like man this just
this just doesn't give like i i get the
localization thing but there's just
sometimes a sentence just doesn't give
me the same feeling when i'm reading in
english versus hearing it in japanese
yeah and it's
yeah i think this is why when you first
start out as an anime fan
you really start to get into it you got
this thing where you're like i only want
pure 100 translation that's all i want
don't [ __ ] don't you dare change any
of the meanings of the words
right i think when you get when you get
into it more and you start you start
watching a lot more anime and then it
becomes a bit tedious to watch
anime and you just kind of want to watch
it dubbed you kind of start to
appreciate when they
appreciate it when they just localize it
and they do it well yeah well it's also
the fact that
sometimes there are just some you know
phrases and like you know
meanings they just don't translate at
all right again i mean like one of the
best dabs of all time
back in it like there's a lot of
sentences that were just like
changed to an extent where it's not even
remotely what the guy said yeah
but it's but it's the same it makes
sense contextually yeah it's the same
kind of feeling but
they've instead of playing it super safe
they were like no no we think we could
improve this for an english audience
which is a bold thing to do
you know we've had a lot of failures
yeah we've had a lot of uh
things that have gone wrong questionable
but i do really appreciate when it's
done right and i appreciate it more so
than an
attempted translation because i feel
like the actors have a way harder time
because i bring japanese dialogue
essentially i mean that's what they do
yeah because it's really hard to also
perform
directly translated to japanese dialogue
to make it sound natural
in english because there's sometimes
where it's like that doesn't sound like
something someone would say in english
yeah you know like i especially felt
that more when i
because like when i did like a bit of
translation work during like school and
stuff like that and i like learnt
linguistics and stuff
like that's where i was like because i
also used to be like how hard could it
be just like direct translating you know
to get the meaning across but then when
i actually started doing i was like
oh no you just can't like it's not a
matter of like preference or anything
like that it's just like you physically
can't there were just some japanese like
ways of saying things that were just
like if i did directly translate it
it would just be a bunch of words yeah i
think because
i don't know if uh even though i spoke
two languages from birth i always
thought
as languages as like they're all just
the same thing
just said in different ways but then
like if that makes sense where
everything can be one-to-one translation
everyone i i can't wait
yeah absolutely and i think because
we've been spoiled because things have
been our whole life
we've just had things that haven't been
read english so we've never known what
the other side is
english it's been translated for us and
even again even though i spoke two
languages
i could never wrap my head around this
concept until i started learning
japanese yeah where i was like
oh it's just like it's it's like another
planet where it hasn't even touched
anything i don't know how to i don't
know how to describe that describe this
like mentality
it's so hard to describe for someone who
only speaks one language right because i
remember the first time i noticed this
was i was watching a thai film with
sydney right
and i you know she obviously had english
subtitles on and
as someone who you know speaks both and
can read english it was
really distracting one because it felt
like i was hearing something
and seeing something and they both meant
the same thing but they felt different
for me it's it's it's
this it's this language dissonance that
i can't quite describe
right but yeah but it's it's something
that i think i feel like
having now trying to learn the language
that you know part of
part of a culture and part of like i
mean like an entire
country's you know way of thinking and
culture is just
ingrained into a language just it's just
so much deeper than just
i say one thing it means another thing
like i would say that depending on what
depending on what language i speak my
personality kind of shifts as well
because
it's it's a different it's a different
kind of way of thinking when you're
speaking another language it's it's it's
so hard to describe
for anyone who only speaks one language
but anyone who does speak
two languages will probably understand
that you probably have a
slightly different personality speaking
one language compared to another because
i
apparently have a completely different
personality when i speak japanese
compared to english
you're a lot softer i'd say yeah yeah
you're a lot smaller english japanese
japanese really i think so i always
thought it was the opposite
i don't maybe i don't know i don't know
yeah
but like i i i also realize as well
because you know sometimes you're in
you're in class or whatever you're
asking oh what is how do i say this in
japanese like no you can't you can't say
that in japanese it doesn't exist in
japanese yeah
it's not a concept yeah they've never
thought of that yeah oh god you just
[ __ ]
like flashback to me in school everyone
being like how do you say [ __ ] in
japanese
okay how do i explain yeah and then like
i realized
because welsh and english because
although
they are entirely different languages
and everyone thinks oh they're just oh
while she's just another version of
english
it's like completely different it's you
know but you're in the uk
like german is closer to english than
welshes like um
and it it's the reason why i think
that i never had this realization before
was because it's the culture that you
grew up in
yeah and because the countries are have
a similar culture now at least in the
modern day
the concepts do sort of translate
because
we've made them translate like we've
made the concept of felt by both
and so there isn't there isn't like the
cultural gap right right because the
cultural gap is like inherently
there's just sayings and stuff that will
never ever have a meaning no matter how
much you try and translate them
no because it's just an inherent it's a
feeling and it's a i don't know this is
just a weird
the concept that we're going down and it
seems so obvious none of us none of us
are linguists this is this is all just
our thoughts from learning a different
language from speaking multiple
languages
um but i think the best thought
experiment i can think of is like any
anyone who speaks english like how would
you explain the concept of the word
[ __ ] to someone who doesn't speak
english and someone who didn't grow up
here
yeah that's like it's it's so i did i
don't
even know where i would begin to start
you know like
like if you didn't if you don't know
like the
you know if you didn't grow up in the
culture if you didn't grow up with
people saying it around you
see hearing that word everywhere i'm
just like how do i explain the right way
to use the word
[ __ ] i mean i literally made a video
with because they made an entire
textbook
purely for the word [ __ ] it's like it's
like a 70 page textbook that goes
through
all the different ways you can use for
yeah and like i thought it was a gag at
first when i bought it but then when i
actually started reading i was like
okay that's how you explain it
apparently there is a way to explain it
it just takes
70 pages and the fact that it takes 70
pages just
shows how complicated it is even though
for us it's just
second nature and it just makes sense
right and like the opposite can be said
for like japanese to english
right like how do you explain to an
english speaker what yoroshuku means
because like it's it's a purely cultural
thing that like it makes complete sense
in japanese
but then every time like every time in
anime they say like yoroshu
there's always a different way of that i
mean it's a different way to translate
depending on the um
context of the scene right yeah what
he's saying and then
like saying i guess so like i guess so
it's like
it's not a thing in japanese right
translate it it's not yeah even even in
wash it's not
yeah like it's it's such an english
thing that because
none of the words mean what the they
mean all together
yeah it's a weird concept that we just
make up we do that with a lot i find
that
faster dude
[Music]
i literally just learned that word today
man i can't even keep up with my own
language
how the [ __ ] are japanese people meant
to keep up with my language
right but going back to anime yeah going
back
again i appreciate exactly so much more
uh obviously
i don't know if you i i watched like two
episodes of yasuke
that was that was pretty good the voice
acting i really enjoyed i need to watch
that as well
um from two episodes i wasn't really
sold on the story
again i knew about the if you don't know
about yasuke the plot is about
essentially
uh nobunaga uh way back in the edo
period uh
had single period single computer sorry
singapore period had uh
just met a black guy at a market and was
like i want him to fight for me yeah and
he was based on a real
person as well yeah and was one of his
closest uh
like allies i guess he was very and the
story kind of explodes
expands on it but i saw a bunch of this
on youtube yeah i thought this would be
a [ __ ] badass anime
[ __ ] you're not like two weeks later got
announced on netflix and i was like wow
i guess i should start wishing for
things yeah yeah it was really it's
really there's i highly encourage you to
go read up about it it's super
interesting
and you just wouldn't expect it it's uh
it's also done by sean thompson
thomas yeah i don't know who the
animation studio is but
oh is it map but i do think that if you
want to learn act
this is not like the best at explaining
at least from the first two episodes i
was like this is
wildly different uh from because i mean
you said there was like magic there's
magic there's mechs and stuff and it's
like i'm like i'm pretty sure that
didn't
exist in feudal japan well yeah i mean
that was literally sean thomas going
[ __ ] it well yeah i get it you're gonna
throw everything in go crazy with it
in some aspect i'm also like this is
such a [ __ ] badass story
by itself yeah that it doesn't need
anything at it it's so goddamn like
the best parts of like again i've only
watched two out of six the best parts
the first two episodes
where the parts were like pre because
there's a there's a time skip
pre-time skip where there's like no
magic or [ __ ] where you're fighting sort
of sword
yeah man-to-man combat it's so goddamn
good and the story and it builds on
although obviously because
you know back then it could be a lot of
issues with race with that yeah of
course
yeah actually of course yeah they
weren't too happy about it when nobunaga
was like this is my best friend yeah
um you know and building on that was so
interesting and i thought like the best
parts anime were that and uh again yeah
i
the story is just so cool like don't
read up about it because there's tons of
youtube videos about it
i actually i actually like went and like
[ __ ] researched so [ __ ] like the
real life yesterday just because like i
had no fun
it's a badass story oh yeah that's
[ __ ] badass yeah yeah it's it
it's like it's just stupid it could be
fictional like
you feel like the mech and magic aspects
added to that story or do you think it
felt out for me personally i didn't
really enjoy it like
i wanted i was hoping you just hope you
you just wanted the story
you liked what i wanted you wanted like
a samurai champagne style like
that yeah yeah but then again like that
historically
well i mean there was a break dancing
samurai but i wanted magic in mexico
the music in the first two episodes is
pretty [ __ ] good yeah yeah exactly
really good the voice acting top [ __ ]
notch even in the japanese it's really
good and like uh you know even in the
japanese jazz game
is played by a black japanese guy which
oh okay
you know it's really cool seeing that
you know why why wouldn't you want that
um
yeah i mean everything else about it i
was digging everything i i
you know i haven't really been motivated
to watch the rest of it
right i think that's because the next
thing is going to put me off in the
magic and stuff
i mean the short clips i watched of it
was [ __ ]
like i didn't realize it was like going
to be that [ __ ] bloody and gory as
well oh dude it's good
like some of the scenes like reminded me
of like a 90s over like ninja scrolls
yeah it was like kill build ninja scroll
like levels of like oh
oh that's oh that's brutal it's so good
i love it
yeah yeah i still haven't seen it but i
i don't check it out
i will definitely check it out you'll
know if it's for you in the first two
episodes it's like i really like the
sean thomas's work anyway so i was going
to watch it
just it's just hard to find time with
all the [ __ ] anime are in the season
and
everything right which you two don't
know about carl i've been meaning to
watch a bunch i mean they need to watch
86.
86 is actually really yeah i i
i probably say that's my favorite oh i
can't say favorite
it's hard it's it's definitely top top
three of my favorite anime out this
season right now
and it just it just feels good to have
an original mecca show
that just gives me the same feeling as
like some of the og mecha shows that
made me really really like the genre
because it feels like it's been so long
since we've just had a
non-gundam non-code geass or non-big
franchise mecha show that true has
actually been
really really good because most of the
mecha shows i remember that's been
coming out recently have either been
like darling in the franxx where i get
invested and it
kind of does [ __ ] that falls flat or
like i really enjoyed great
trigger is like let me introduce you
well then you've had things like
uh sss grid man which [ __ ] amazing
show but it's like
it's a mecca show but it's also a bit
togesatsu so it's not like it's
it's it's like it's like it's not like a
vanilla make
[Music]
yeah but 86 you know gives me the same
feelings of when i was when i will first
watch code gas
are seven all the mechs that i watched
in the mid-2000s that really made me
love the [ __ ] genre um it's still
early days i don't know if it's gonna be
like 24 episodes or 12 episodes where
there's gonna be a complete
story i'm really hoping so but it's just
really really good
i mean do you know do you know the story
of it at all i don't want to know
anything oh i've heard that that's good
yeah i'm going to watch it yeah just
going to a blind is the best way i think
i watched uh the way of the husband on
netflix as well i have the house husband
that's it yeah yeah i mean i enjoyed it
a lot i thought it was very funny i was
i haven't had an anime maybe laugh out
loud constantly
it's fine it's hilarious it's like two
hours i mean it's i thought it was gonna
be
like 10 episodes 24 minutes but it's
like five episodes of like 12 15 minutes
yeah i only saw
three episodes i was like i got the rest
of the season to binge i didn't know it
was only five episodes
yeah okay i kind of it kind of sucked
that it literally just
like it was just ended it was like this
is less skit
bye-bye and then it was like there was
no ending or anything it wasn't right
see you next time or anything and there
was
it was just like okay skid over go the
[ __ ] home get out of here
because because each of the chapters in
the manga are really really short yeah
they're like maybe like five six pages
like max
well i thought the pacing was fantastic
um i know obviously it caused a lot of
controversy with the animation
yeah i saw a lot of people claiming on
twitter ah
i just couldn't decide i flip-flopped
there were some sketches where i felt
they did it really good
yeah and there was somewhere i'm like
holy [ __ ] this was so lazily done
right and it depended on the sketch well
i think it just went down to the
classification because i think we've
briefly talked about this in
trash days after that like my opinion of
it was that it's
not so much an anime in the traditional
sense where it's basically just
a motion comic it is it is just a moment
that and advertises that yeah instead of
but i i adapted i do
yeah but i feel if you've labeled it as
motion comic adaptation then i think
less people would have been interested
in it right unfortunately unfortunately
but then also you said because i've set
this expectation that this is going to
be a thing that might happen because i
feel like it was that and it being on
netflix as well netflix really picking
this up which
gave it like people what preconceived
expectations because to me
i watched it i thought it was funny as
[ __ ] i thought the animation worked for
some of the jokes
like it's it's up there with like i
thought it was just as funny as like
sakamoto for me if not funnier
yeah yeah like it was so goddamn funny
and it scratched that itch that i didn't
know i was longing for
yeah i was every single episode i was
[ __ ] cackling laughing out loud
it's like that weird like surrealist
comedy right he's so good you just don't
know what's what he's going to say next
yeah right and every time you feel like
you've figured out how absurd he is he
just does something else
yeah he's [ __ ] funny if you have if
you haven't watched it please go and
watch it it's just about like a yakuza
member who gets married and straightens
out and has become a housewife
yeah and yeah it's just really funny but
it would have been like a it would have
been a nine or a 10 for me if
again like i don't know if i don't
really like the the motion comic style
well would you do you think it would
have been funnier with say just mediocre
adaptation
like mediocre animation so really
genuinely yeah
because there was so little animation on
it anyway and there's just times i'm
like i wish they just did a little bit
on this just to help sell the joke
i i feel like the lack of animation help
sell some jokes
if anything i agree i agree some of them
just just because it some of it just
looked ridiculous and that to me just
made it more funny
but imagine this anime in like nintendo
style yeah but like
name another comedy anime that's on
niche joe level
there isn't but i'm just saying like if
you had the choice no if i had the
choice between
that i'd always go for [ __ ] nietzsche
animation even like corner super
animation right yeah because connoisseur
i think a lot of people underestimate
how good the character animation in
conor super is that really sold
so much of the voice acting performance
where a lot of other comedy anime i feel
have fallen flat
because you have amazing voice acting
performance you have amazing source
material
and the animation is just like the okay
okay animation everybody does nothing to
enhance
these i think i was just shocked at
how little there was yeah whereas with
where the house husband
had amazing voice acting obviously had
amazing source material and i feel like
because they didn't try it kind of like
suited that comedy style perfectly
right and and and and i feel like to me
if you couldn't have
amazing animation i would have preferred
to have it have like just
not not even like bad animation just
like a very unique style of limited
animation that really helps sell some of
the
weirder and more ridiculous parts of the
manga because it is a ridiculous manga
and i feel like the animation style
helped incentuate some of the ridiculous
moments to me yeah there's some moments
where i was like yeah okay this joke
works
with this animation there's others where
i'm like yeah this really needed more
to help some of this joke i don't know
that personally i feel like maybe a mix
could have like
really really propelled it did you have
you seen clips of the
there's a japanese live-action
adaptation have you seen this i've seen
it
it's so bad it's it's so funny
it's like it's it's tragic wait what's
uh describe it to me
it's just like okay the main guy it
looks like a cosplay
it doesn't it is a cosplay yeah like it
looks like a cosplay not like an actual
actor and yeah huh like the guy isn't
like built enough
he's quite it is like formal alchemist
like that and then his friend oh
and then his friend in the anime who was
really young and supposed to be like the
young gang member yeah
looks really [ __ ] old and like i mean
i didn't watch it like fully
i only watched like clips of it on
youtube and i was like oh no
it's bad because i i there's like a
there's a i watch the same ski
both of them compared yeah like the the
humor just wasn't
nearly as good in uh the live action
like the i don't know why i feel like
they didn't like because with animation
you can really sell the absurdity and
then the
like that's yeah yeah but yeah but they
didn't work very well yeah yeah
i feel like also japanese acting and tv
shows i don't know how they are so bad
but i've never seen japanese acting in a
tv show and been like that's fantastic
unless it's like ken watson literally
he's the only one yeah
i feel bad saying that cause i feel like
there's such a broad statement but i've
i've watched so much japanese tv
and all the drama acting is appalling
yeah it's not
it's so bad yeah especially in like the
live action
like especially when a live-action anime
adaptation of a
japanese tv show or a japanese anime
it's it's always
it's so weird seeing live-action actors
try to act like anime characters or
doing like the anime style
because because you watch like korean
dramas and korean adaptations of stuff
and it's so much better
korea like i watched uh like sweet home
uh the webtoon uh adaptation okay into
netflix and the actors were [ __ ]
amazing in it was a live action app it's
a live action
and the actors every single time i've
watched a korean movie or korean drama
i'm always so impressed at how [ __ ]
good not
not saying that the acting isn't bad but
yeah i just thought for some reason i'm
like oh i've seen japanese acting
it's gonna be right yeah it's gonna be
over the top dramatic
all the time it's like i mean i i feel
like especially in recent years korean
movies and korean
dramas and shows have just like they
they are
like they are way ahead of like japanese
j-dramas and dream movies i mean there's
so many movies where i'm like [ __ ]
competitive english like [ __ ] something
like some of the like old boy is like i
love that movie [ __ ]
and that's like that's actually based on
a manga did you know
i didn't yeah oh really yeah oh old boy
was originally a manga oh
i got adopted into a korean movie and
like oh that's cool that is that that
movie is like one of my favorite movies
of all time yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean it's so
goddamn good in that movie i [ __ ]
said that
photography is fantastic that's one of
the greatest foreign films of all time
and it's so
you know it's so good you know it's up
there as with like parasites is like
from to me it's one of the best career
korean movies i've seen so i've seen a
lot there are
so many good korean movies right and i
feel like
people are now just figuring out that
man koreans make good movies
yeah they're very good yeah train to
busan as well i remember the first time
fantastic
first time watching train to busan i was
like i've seen zombie movies i know how
this works and for some reason
it didn't do like on like uh you know on
paper it doesn't do
that much different to every other
zombie movie but it's just so [ __ ]
good
yeah i i i can't pinpoint why it was so
good
but it's just i don't know what it is
like when i watch japanese tv i feel
like it's like a pantomime
you know what i mean it does feel like
it feels like that level of acting where
it's like
is there somebody behind me i better not
look
and then no it's like because i feel i
feel like with japanese acting it's it's
very reminiscent to anime or anime
acting
which anime acting works for anime but
it doesn't work for live-action acting
at all
yeah well i was asking some friends i'm
like oh i was like because i was
watching with them like
oh are they famous are they famous
they're like oh yeah they're a famous
voice actor
it's like when you're a famous voice
actor you can get roles in tv shows yeah
yeah yeah it's kind of strange because
it's normally the other way around
yeah right with uh you know western
stuff and it's just odd to think because
i feel like
you know as someone who does voice
acting it does not translate to the like
irl yeah like it's a completely
different skill set yeah
yeah i mean you you understand the
fundamentals of acting
but you know can you hit the mark you
know you're not being told how to walk
you're not being told how to act
physically
yeah that's it you do have to learn that
is separate but
there's a lot you don't think about yeah
yeah yeah and it's
interesting i i just wonder why i sit
there and i'm just confused i'm like why
is japanese acting like generally
not as good and not not saying that
there's no there's zero japanese good
actors just saying
in general the tv production is pretty
lackluster
i think maybe it's because like they
don't really think of like the outs like
outside of japan movie industry as much
of a competition like they might think
it's like because you know
with like you know hollywood films or
like english-speaking films right like
you're not only competing with hollywood
but you're competing with literally
every other english-speaking country
right every other english speaking
production
whereas i feel the japanese film
industry is kind of in its
own bubble but they're kind of just like
no
no driving force there's no like driving
force like a threat
to make them be like we got to step up
our game or like or maybe
the fact that like they're probably like
just unaware
right they probably just think like well
you know english-speaking productions
and like other productions that aren't
japanese
do this in this way but for us this
works
with our type of audience so there's no
like they they probably don't even think
this is bad acting right i'm sure people
are going to comment be like
there are so many good japanese films
there are a lot of good japanese films
but it's a lot rarer to find
a really really good japanese they can't
find a few in between yeah yeah because
especially in like
j dramas i feel like even hot holy [ __ ]
that's what i mean that's where you
really
i i feel like i feel you see the
pinnacle yeah i i feel like the right
way to describe j
dramas from like the majority i've
watched is just
they are very campy yeah that's right
right yeah yeah yeah everything is
[ __ ] so campy and
you know there there's there's an
audience for that and there's like a um
you know there's
you know i do enjoy some j dramas but
it's it's it's
less of i think this is a good show and
more just like i i can just get behind
this show you know i i like i like
whatever source material is adapting
and also i don't frankly i don't give a
[ __ ] about cinematography right
i don't really care too much i'm not
very picky you know well that's good
because j drama has
zero well that's what we're going to say
well j dramas they shoot it like a
[ __ ]
like a daytime tv commercial why does it
look like that
like i never thought i would give a [ __ ]
about that until i watched jade
that's the point you don't give a [ __ ]
about cinematography until you use
something you see something that has no
cinematography yeah
right it's like what are you gonna
[ __ ] advertise me a plunger that does
four in one any second now i'm waiting
for it so how it's shot it's ridiculous
i don't know why it looks like that it's
so weird
yeah i feel like i've seen some youtube
videos with better cinematography than
some of the stuff out there in jade
broad in japan channel yeah 100 percent
that'll make christmas day
that'll make up for the lack of his
signature
yeah i mean i i hate [ __ ] on it i
don't really know i don't really
understand
why i don't really know if they care i
don't really know if there's a want to
improve i
i just i just don't i just don't think
the audience is there no
no the audience doesn't give a [ __ ] well
it's normal i mean i mean the majority
of the population he was older so
yeah generally i mean to be fair i have
seen a bunch of j dramas where the
cinematography is absolute ass
but i've still enjoyed it because the
story was just genuinely really really
good
yeah and it wasn't until like it was
like an afterthought of like
oh yeah that was a good j drama but the
cinematography was [ __ ]
i saw this one and it was like i think
it was like a james bond show
and it was like a this japanese guy
looked like japanese george clooney it
was really cool really
i mean holy [ __ ] this guy's hot i think
i know who you're talking about actually
yeah he's kind of he looks kind of
western he looks western but he's but
i looked it up and he's a hundred
percent japanese yeah but he looks like
george clooney if he was japanese
and he was just like a no-nonsense
attitude guys like i'm coming to get the
information and just like beat this guy
up but with just terrible lighting and
cinematography
but it was like really i don't know why
i'm talking about this i was just
fascinated by him i was like that meant
so goddamn hot good for him
i wish i was that because i've always
because i've had like the movie
experience of
wow this movie has [ __ ] fantastic
cinematography
yeah unfortunately the rest of the movie
is [ __ ] you know
what was that what was that movie it was
a it was the
something still water or something where
it's like um
no no it was originally supposed to be
the bioshock movie but then they like
changed it halfway through
i have no yeah let me look it up
yeah i know exactly what it is but like
the movie had like the most like
amazing [ __ ] cinematography it looked
[ __ ] incredible like it was
stylized perfectly really creepy
photography
yeah look it up um yeah i mean i
remember a cure for wellness i haven't
seen that movie yeah that was those
that's a horror movie yeah the horror
movie yeah for wellness that was
apparently that was originally supposed
to be the bioshock movie and you can
tell
nothing like bioshock no obviously they
like completely change the story once
that threw me off when you said it's
meant to be the bioshock movie and his
supposedly was supposed to be the
bioshock movie but then something
happened with lee gal
d wise and they were like all right time
to rewrite the story completely but like
when you just look at the cinematography
and like the sets and stuff like that
i'm like okay i can kind of see what
they were going for
like this looks cool it's very stylized
cinematography is great
unfortunately the story was like what
like what the [ __ ] is happening nothing
makes sense characters were all [ __ ]
so like that's when i got to the point i
was like would i have preferred this
movie
if it had [ __ ] cinematography but a good
story versus
great cinematography but a shoot story
and this is like the animation versus
story debate the anime fans go through
right like which do you prefer
i mean if you had to choose story story
story like has to be well acted you know
you can't tell me on a bad story with
not with actors who don't sell the
moment for you right the room is pretty
good
yeah i mean no because like i i feel
like i guess watching a lot of j
drums reminds me of like the old
thai soap operas i would see my mom
watching and i'm just like what the [ __ ]
is this mom
like what the hell are you watching i i
feel like the indian shows as well yeah
i feel like that's just i feel
like that's just a genre of itself
where you got like the campiest most
melodrama [ __ ] going on
you don't know what's going on you see
out of context clips i think i think
even some korean dramas do this as well
it's just not as well known like i
remember seeing
one clip where it was a korean drama and
somebody's falling down the stairs
no that's the bollywood one right there
i think that's the
takes this bollywood like [ __ ]
cabbage of kimchi
and just slaps this guy with it
and i just like i just want to know the
context of this
because context it just makes no sense
we just have to remind our audience that
this is a korean production
bring out the kimchi
didn't like uh didn't pewdiepie react to
like a bollywood clip and then there was
like drama or something about it
like they're like i swear there was draw
i don't know if man if i'm remembering
this incorrectly but like he
there was like a clip that he reacted to
and it was because there was like a
reaction image where she was like oh and
then it was like
20 shots of it going like zooming in
yeah it's the woman falling off like the
bell straight right is that oh i've seen
that one the guy's like slow motion
trying to catch him but like it's like
going back and forth and it's like this
woman's been in the air for five minutes
it's the second floor why is this woman
like literally [ __ ] air bending right
in front of my eyes
everyone's just like watching it in slow
motion it's [ __ ] hilarious i love
that
i swear she got into some spat or
something because of it you keep talking
yeah yeah no that's what i i would love
to react to indian
like soap operas out of context yeah i
feel like there's every other soap opera
and then there's just indian soap operas
oh yeah yeah
they take campiness to the next level
and it's so amazing
have you ever have you ever seen like
many bollywood movies
there was a period in my life where i
tried to get into bollywood movies but
the problem
is is that there are so many [ __ ]
films in the bollywood likes
yeah i didn't realize how many movies
they made like
it's like they make like [ __ ] like
five ten times as much as like hollywood
right yeah
it's insane so i'm just like i
legitimately was like
where the [ __ ] do i even begin because
like i don't know anybody else who like
has stepped into that territory
yeah so like my only other option was to
like go on the internet be like
best holy bollywood movies right top 10
bollywood
films of all time thank you mojo here's
my watch list right now but then
every [ __ ] like top 10 top 50 list i
saw was just like all completely
there wasn't a single like entry where
it was like oh i saw that on this page
it's all [ __ ] different so i'm like
what do i just have to like
yeah do i literally do i literally just
have to like
that's a great movie i remember when
that came out people like yeah i like
bollywood yeah like
millionaires that's good it's good yeah
so i'm like do i just have to like bite
the ball and just like
pick a random one and just like hope
that it's a good movie
i don't know yeah i don't know i think
please let us know in the comments
what's a good bollywood film
the only one i can remember that i
watched i think it's really good um
there's a film called three idiots
and the only reason i watched it was
because it was on the imdb top 100 at
the time
right like what is this and it's it's a
concept i feel like that was made for
indians right
because it's a con it's a film get this
about engineers
and i think i think it was like actual i
can't remember if they were mechanical
engineers or electrical engineers
it doesn't matter they're engineers it
was just so weird seeing this
engineering movie and then out of
nowhere they just break out into song
and dance
like there's nothing i hate more than
[ __ ] musicals i cannot stand
like musicals i hate musicals i i
actually agree
really yeah it's like if i want a
musical i'll [ __ ] pause the movie and
go on spotify and play damn
for four minutes and i'll put i don't
get in the way man
i i hate i hate musicals so goddamn much
i
cannot i would rather do anything else
i'm like
i'm very hit or miss with musicals like
a lot of musicals i'm just like
[ __ ] whatever but then if you like
like i could watch like rocky horror
like 30 times i feel like muse i feel
like to me musical works
well on like when it's a stage you know
when it's oh
it's a really really amazing experience
like i remember watching lesbians of
robs
[ __ ] miserables there's miserables
um i remember watching that uh in
england at the west end
[ __ ] amazing experience yeah um and
then i remember watching the movie and
i'm just like this is
really boring i don't know i watched it
for the first time because
like like pretty recently just because
aki was like oh you have to watch it
it's like you're dead it's great like
i'm just like okay well you know i
always give musicals a go so it's
whatever
this this might be the rare time where
like rocky horror where it's like oh my
[ __ ] fall in love with it i'm just
like
god damn they haven't stopped singing
for like two hours it just feels like a
[ __ ] quick time event
like when you're in a musical
it just feels like it doesn't [ __ ]
end it's like unskippable cut scenes and
[ __ ] it's like get the [ __ ] out of here
well what i like about like rocky horror
for instance right is that like one it's
[ __ ] weird
two it's [ __ ] tim curry in like
leggings which is just like amazing just
conceptually yeah but like what i like
about rocky hard compared to like say
like
les les miserables is like les
miserables just like
90 singing and then 10 dialogue
whereas rocky horror is like 50 50. so
it's like you get the enjoyment of like
an actual
movie like type of story yeah but when
it's every now and then it goes into
like
song but when i'm watching a musical i'm
just like just get to the story
why am i here i don't care about this
song and dodge just get to the story
give me the story the only time actually
i actually think i liked musical was um
what is it there's a little little shop
of horrors right that has like a lot of
music in it the one with the big plan
oh yes yes yes that's musical right yeah
yeah yeah i think i like that because it
made the thing [ __ ] terrifying when
it started singing
i was like it sold me on the horror
because when there's this giant plant
puppet started singing i was getting
[ __ ] is it like a 15 year old kid like
hold on [ __ ] it's like the kind of like
jazzy style like
yeah yeah that's terrifying
did you have uh did you ever watch bugs
me alone as a kid but what
luckily malone i know the name yeah i
don't know anything about it though
yeah it's uh i i can't remember because
i only have vivid
memories of watching as a kid all i know
it was like it's like set in like you
know
in the prohibition era right uh and it's
about a bunch of people running
speakeasies
but for some reason everyone every one
of the gangsters
who are you know who are in this movie
everyone's played by kids
right and when they have tommy guns
instead of firing bullets
they fire like a cream pie so whenever
someone gets hit by a cream pie in the
face
they're dead it's like thinking back as
a kid it's the most like
this is the weirdest fever dream i'm
describing right now
but it exists this is right it sounds
like a david lynch film you know it's
like it's like that
weird it sounds like on the same level
what are those [ __ ] dogs called the
movies where they
like they just dub over dogs
it's literally like air buddy or some
[ __ ] it's like a whole [ __ ] series
oh like snow dogs like that level yeah
literally
like that where they just [ __ ] dub
over dogs doing [ __ ] like what the [ __ ]
dude
oh my god i've been trying to find
someone else in my life who also has
this vivid memory of watching bugs me
alone as a kid
because i just want to reconfirm that i
that was real it really happened
i just need to know okay and i so far
i've
you know maybe it was just my school
thing maybe it was
my generation thing i don't know but i
have not met a single other person
irl who remembers watching bugs me alone
so please comment section
if there's someone in the comments
section who knows and who has watched
buxy malone before
please please tell me because i need to
know i'm not [ __ ] crazy
i need to know this wasn't a meant i
need to know this wasn't a fever dream
i need to know if this really happened
everyone in the comments just be like i
have no idea i have no idea
i don't
yeah that's why i remember it was the
music i sleep real question though did
you guys watch the cats movie
no i didn't i didn't i saw how did you
watch it
because i was just like because i who
doesn't look at that trailer and thinks
this looks like [ __ ] i'ma watch it you
know when you uh
you just see ads so often for something
that you've decided that you've decided
you're gonna dislike this thing before
you even see anything
that was me with cats because it was
just everywhere it was so obnoxious
and they do that thing where like this
has never been done before yeah this is
this is literally never been done before
like they just say that about anything
like
we've never had this we've never
experienced this we all felt amazing on
the set
well the thing is with cats the things
with cats is that i've seen
it uh on stage before yeah and like i
actually thought not my favorite musical
but i was like okay out of all the
musicals i've seen on stage
it's pretty alright it's pretty decent
like it's good story the songs are
pretty alright
but then when you watch that trailer and
you see the horrific things in that
trailer you're just like
well i've you have peaked my interest
now yes
[ __ ] green screen like huge artists
like on these like [ __ ] cat
like basically these huge actors being
furries i swear there was like real
displays i spent those like really funny
like cached interviews
really well like the cast were like i
don't [ __ ] know
what do you want to say i love it when
actors
like give interviews and they just
[ __ ] [ __ ] on what they're in
all i hope is like there's something
really cathartic about it
and like they're like yeah it shucks
like the [ __ ] robert patterson one
right
yeah the wrong person is like i can't
[ __ ] twilight i can't [ __ ] stand
twilight
like robert patterson please have we
spoke about this before the podcast
yeah i think we're talking about him
friday well like hated being in twilight
and his interviews about it are so
[ __ ] funny yeah
and please as well going uh like daniel
craig
in james bond did we talk about this i
don't remember
literally can't remember if we talked
about apologies apologies if we said it
already sorry
we must spoke about it on set i think
because daniel craig
hates being in double 07 and james bond
yeah
the interviews that he gave were so
[ __ ] funny well he did he said
he did like a quote where he said like
i'd rather cut myself than do another
bond film
and then he did another bond
it's so funny it's just like it's so
tragic
it's like imagine getting hired back
again by the people you're just [ __ ]
on yeah
i would rather die than work for you
again and they're like let's get them
back
let's get this guy back like how out of
options must they be
to have to like bring daniel craig back
here they must have thrown so much money
because i'm pretty sure he must have
signed a contract before otherwise is
this
like really yeah because you know once
if you break contract i'm pretty sure
that
you're just like blacklisted from
hollywood right because that's why no
one's like no one really breaks contract
either that'll they must have given
daniel craig a fat [ __ ] paycheck
i'm sure they gave him a lot of money
yeah i'm pretty sure they just gave him
a lot of money didn't they have to do
something because he like
in the which which movie was it was it
uh
what was the most recent film uh there
was one
the one off the skyfall right yeah the
one up the sky there's one off the
skyfall
yeah god i'm so behind on my body well
there was there was one where
in the casino it was a casino scene it's
knocking around
where he he was about to say
whether that one yeah type and daniel
craig gloves
there was a thing where they had to like
cgi i think gloves on or off of him
because he just left them on because he
liked them or something
yeah yeah so yeah he bought he bought
gloves
yeah before like filming and he really
wanted he really wanted to wear them
and so they had to like cgi the gloves
off of him
because he wanted to wear them is that
right can you google it
it was something like that where he was
so [ __ ] done with this [ __ ] that he
impulse bought gloves and was like i'm
wearing them on the film i don't give a
[ __ ] just cgi them off of them
see jonathan like cracking their necks
being like all right
i couldn't do that just out of a feeling
horrible to the people who have to work
on that cgi
but oh you've got to respect the level
of i don't give a [ __ ]
that's just that's just a new level of
just yeah just
you don't give a [ __ ] you just [ __ ]
most passive aggressive way of being
like don't call me back please
you're literally on like a half a
billion dollar movie
and you just don't give a [ __ ] about
wearing your like 20 200
gloves you're like ah who cares like
it's just it's also just like the choice
of gloves
as well of all things you could have put
on it's just like the biggest [ __ ] you
right
it's just i don't know what a [ __ ]
hilarious it's just so cathartic to just
hear this i don't know why it's so funny
just hearing
individuals be like [ __ ] you big movie
corporation i'm going to do what i want
and then they just roll with it like i i
guess we'll fix it in post
yeah i guess we can't get him to take
his gloves off
[Music]
and he's in the new one as well and i
think the new one is supposedly his last
one
yeah but it got delayed because covered
so pretty sure that's what they said
about skyfall as well yeah they said
that about last like three films
but they don't know who's going to
replace himself well that's so weird
right because i remember a time like
you know in like the late 90s early
2000s where like i feel i feel
every james bond movie there was a
different james bond no they did like
two or three i think each at least
but i feel like they were like replacing
them like quicker than
daniel craig right no i mean chris
brosnan did a lot here's roswell
yeah maybe yeah but he probably also
enjoyed it okay
maybe
what else has daniel craig done apart
from james bond he's done a few pretty
good films
not i can't remember any off the top of
my head he did like i really liked him
in like layer cake
oh
i like him in everything else but james
bond i think he's really good
in everything but james bond yeah but i
i feel like in layer cake he also just
played daniel craig right
he just kind of played james bond in a
different skin you know it was
it it kind of very felt james bond it
was daniel craig playing james blonde
playing daniel yeah i feel like james
bond is just
an outdated archetype like i feel like
it is you watch it nowadays and you're
like they've they've tried their best to
kind of introduce
it yeah but it still feels like when
they're trying to put like
the playboy scenes in you're like this
is kind of cringe yeah i don't know why
but just seeing a guy just go
yes
[Music]
it's a very stated archetype like i
can't imagine anyone
like imagine if i'm just like my name's
manny tappo
tapper with that outfit
you're wearing the turtlenecks
well that's why i really enjoyed uh
king's name right
steve steve kingston was good until the
second movie
yeah yeah that's why i really liked the
first movie because it completely just
like
almost made fun of that like it was
really good i really liked it and then
and then it became the architect and
then it became the archetype yeah
exactly yeah
so that was how the [ __ ] did we get on
about james bond films i don't [ __ ]
we're talking about musicals oh have you
ever seen the i was thinking about
musicals
i was thinking about musicals i actually
liked the only ones i probably actually
like were
um the south park movie uh yeah
did you guys ever see the book of mormon
live i've it's literally been the one
the musical that i've always wanted to
watch dude that's a [ __ ] amazing
musical yeah
and the reason i like those musicals is
the music is funny and it plays offline
joke and it doesn't
it like i don't care about the story i
don't know i don't care about the story
of south parks i i'm there for the jokes
and that
helps add on to the jokes that's why
it's it's the only musical i can get
behind
but yeah i'm i'm not really that much of
a broadway or west end guy so i've
already seen him really
really i thought you seem like a
broadway kind of gentleman can't stop
you from singing why do i seem like a
theater kid to you
have you ever been tempted to go watch
like the the anime like musicals
have you seen any of them tempted or
there's no
that they've restarted the definite one
right yeah
how does that work how i have been so
tempted to go and watch it
just to say i went to go see a death
note musical or like the prince of
tennis musical you know i really want to
go
no you know that idea wasn't in my head
but now it is in my head yeah i really
[ __ ] want i've been trying to find
people
to come with me to go watch like any of
the anime musicals just because
there's something there's something like
defeatist about being like
yeah so uh i went to go watch there's no
musical by myself the other day you know
as you do on a sunday
dude i'd [ __ ] do it yeah please [ __ ]
that i'll i'll go i'll go by myself to
watch the death
musical well yeah they might they had
the my hero academia musical didn't they
as well
yeah they did they did i just i'm i'm
that idea wasn't in my head but now i'm
just genuinely curious
what how does that work how how do you
how would you adapt how do you adapt
death note
to a musical like eating apples
die
i want it to be in the style of like a
willy wonka esque it's like original you
know like
just have ryoka be like a number just
have that kind of sing a song
is extremely poor as well yeah it's just
the shittest costume
today it's literally a guy in like a
pupil a guy like a [ __ ] costume
yeah like he's just been like taught and
feathered
and he's just kind of like overweight
and he's like no just like smoke his
voice as well
and a cigarette oh it's just [ __ ]
william dufoe without any makeup on it
it's just wanting him to fun before it
comes i was like
i'd buy it he's very good actor yeah
he's great if anyone
if anyone could just stand there and
make me accept it it's pretty will you'd
be fine
yeah yeah of course god i'm just
remembering the death note live action
movie now oh
he was the best part of the movie he was
the best part of the movie
he said four lines and that was it
unfortunately
but he was good that was good in those
four lines how do we get onto this how
do we tangent so hard i don't know i
don't know
we're good at that so gentlemen moving
on though this is
now our last few moments in the studio
yeah yeah this is this is the last
episode of
season one i guess i guess it is if it's
gonna cost
i don't know if we're doing like season
one via studios or via the year
um i mean either way this is the end
right because i think
we're like right on as we're recording
this is like one year anniversary i'm
pretty sure
i'm pretty sure i don't know 53 right
yeah
yeah so yeah yeah 53 or 50 close enough
oh that's 52 weeks in a year and uh
and the one over here yeah yeah of
course
yeah wow i mean it felt a lot longer
than a year to be honest
i don't remember the studio being this
full you know i don't remember
i don't remember what it looked like
before it's scary going back to like
episode one yeah
and being like it doesn't look like the
same room i'll tell you what
after you mentioned it on the trash
taste awards i
remember looking at the first episode
again as well and i forgot that we
originally had our camera
all the way back there yeah so it kind
of looked like you were peeking through
like
like
you know you're peeking through being
like oh what are they getting onto and
now it just feels like way too close
hello this is
the new camera angle that we changed to
you know well like
30 episodes ago yeah just it just feels
it just feels weird i forgot that we
changed camera angles and the different
feeling that they gave off
um and yeah like i'm impressed how many
guests we got this year as well
that's uh yeah given the limited
circumstances of all nine of them
yeah uh but yeah i'm sure chris will be
on again yeah
of course no man i'm sure chris is going
to come knocking on this
is he going to be the first guest on in
season two as well he said he wants to
be
just asserting dominance to every other
guest i don't see why not i
didn't ask what else is there to talk
about with chris what do you mean just
have chris on each
insanity and shoes chris christie makes
funny moments by being
on your bully chris chris bully's ours
you know that's a good deal looking
forward to what drip he's gonna be
wearing next after
after winning laziest drip in season
season one
he's you know like after that episode
goes on he's gonna be like
oh i gotta come with like a suit i told
chris i was like you won an award by the
way
he's like you want two awards no no no
no he said and i was like oh yeah
you're one of the awards he's already
really i was like yeah yeah just one
i was like [ __ ] off
yeah but i guess uh yeah i guess by the
time you see us next week
we'll be in a hopefully brand new setup
yeah it'll be like a month for us we'll
be like
one week for you guys yeah sweet for you
guys yeah we want to remodel and uh
change the setup a little bit get the
angles down we're not gonna have like a
completely different setup right off the
bat i think it's it's gonna be similar
to season one where we
kind of grow our set as the season goes
on you know i i feel i i like
well you haven't decided everything yet
but we have no idea what the new set's
gonna look like i wanna get
all new figures that's what i want that
get rid of that involves having another
akihabara special which is going to be
pretty hard right now
considering yeah everything is locked
down
so maybe you'll have to wait a little
bit longer compared to season one to get
a new akihabara special
um but we do want to do one in the
future um
apart from that i don't know what other
plans i'm i'm just excited to show you
guys
like the new set though yeah and having
a proper trash taste office not just
an apartment that we just remodeled into
a set i mean you'll get you guys will
see it in the after dark vlog i mean
like speaking of like there'll be way
more after
content as well yeah we're gonna have
two sets now so the after dark specials
aren't just going to be trash taste 1.5
yeah oh yeah i mean that's the main i
think that's one of the big reasons why
we want to move is just to
allow us to make more yeah more content
because right now it's you know i mean
you can make content in this room i'm
sure we could but
it's one of those things where but at
what cost well yeah when you're in a
room that you just
despise yeah it's too cramped you don't
want to make
like stuff you don't feel creative you
don't feel like you want to do anything
like you guys will see when we vlog it
but like behind the set is an absolute
mess and actually i mean the set is a
mess yeah the entire room is the entire
place is a mess
everything the beauty of camera angles
is everything looks bigger
but this is it is not as neat as you
think it is in fact
like i get actually like physically
embarrassed whenever a guest comes oh
yeah that's pretty embarrassing
yeah because the one thing the one
mutual thing that every guest says is
wow this place is a lot smaller than it
looks
like yeah we know we know it's it's like
you know when your mom comes in and your
room isn't tidy that's what i feel like
you know the first thing i feel like
saying is apologizing
and then the second thing is like
whoever has to explain to the guest
that they're going to be sitting here
and the first thing you have to explain
to them is how to get here and you're
just like
oh you just gotta go around the set i
think like you cannot see
any of the desk and we have three desks
over there yeah at the wall you can't
see any of the desk
my desk is a [ __ ] war zone that melee
is turned into which would you which was
the guest
that thought you had to go under again
who was that reyna
oh yeah yeah i think it was great enough
there was so little space reynolds
literally thought that you had to go
under the table are they honestly
there's pretty more room under the table
yeah honestly probably i don't know
i can't believe there's less of a trippy
hazard under here i can't fault her for
thinking about honestly
yeah everything every the way we've done
it is all it works but it's
literally the meme of like the cheeto
holding the door along yeah yeah
yeah yeah like everything works but it's
not clean
it can be about like it looks good i'm
happy with how it look considering what
we've done it's the most scuffed way we
can of it
looking as good as it does and sounding
as good as it does but yeah we want to
we already want to upgrade it and
i don't know get a better system in
general just for everything have more
guests on you know have guests on after
dark
you know just having everything upgraded
everything better you know and uh
you know it's because of you guys that
we're even able to [ __ ] move toward
you know yeah yeah yeah yeah without the
patreon stuff we would definitely
be able to consider the upgrades that
we're doing absolutely basically when we
started this podcast we we were just
like what's the minimum we can get away
with in case
this podcast is like zero crashes just
crashes and burns immediately
yeah so we planned this on like as much
of a budget as much money as we were
willing to put in
yeah essentially yeah how much money do
we want to lose and then also hours do
we want to lose
yeah exactly yeah exactly but like yeah
i mean again like we said this in the
previous episode with the the trash
taste
awards obviously but we're very we're
very grateful i think for the
crazy amount of support i think if you
told us that we'd be this close to a
million subs after one year i think we'd
have been like
funny that'd be like a thing a hundred
thousand subs that's a success
because we only we only pushed this
channel like once twice on
our main channels yeah once in a at the
end of the start of a video or end of a
video and then
the happy and then the academic
especially considering it's everything
else is
driven by like twitter and you guys just
enjoying the show
yes you guys spreading the good word
it's uh it's crazy man it's crazy to see
it and it's like because normally
with a lot of podcasts i see you have
like with big names in them you have
like the big announcements so you've got
the big trickle of views
yeah and then the view the view just
like drips down which is what i was
expecting and i wasn't expecting us to
maintain like
the view count yeah for 50 episodes
it's also intimidating because now i
know that the stuff the dumb [ __ ] i say
will be in front of more people than
ever
yeah right yeah one thing one thing i
certainly was surprised by was just
like just realizing that some of the
[ __ ] we say to each other people
like hundreds of thousands of people are
now listening to you yeah
i forget about everything i [ __ ] say
like same here all the dumb [ __ ] like i
got emailed today about baked beans
about one of the semi-baked beans i
totally forgot i said i like baked beans
and someone's offering to send me a ton
of baked beans and i'm like i'm
flattered
you can't say no to that i just can't
remember
why i said this i i've totally think
about this
just sounds like a random person wanting
to sing beans i know i went on the rant
about loving baked beans
but that was one of those things where
i'm very passionate at the moment and
then when i when i leave i totally
forget that i
had a rant about it exactly yeah and i'm
like i did i did talk very passionately
about baked beans that is me
i feel that's a lot of moments right i
mean sometimes you just get passionate
when you're talking with your mates or
when you're in like a [ __ ] is it kaya
or having like an argument where it's
not really an argument and you're just
you're just very passionate in the
moment you reckon we'll get any comments
people like men
i like the old set more there's a better
vibe to it well the table's gonna be the
same
i stopped watching after season one
season one is when it went downhill yeah
two is a real letter
i mean essentially it's not too much is
going to change really
really okay two two two to like bring
down expectations really the reason we
want to change
um change offices is because this is not
a convenient office
at all um on camera we don't want too
much to change
uh we just want to work more comfortably
instead of having this like the most
jank [ __ ] setup for everything we do
i mean
right now trash chase after dark is
running off of my laptop
okay there's five three giant ass hdmis
going into this man's laptop yeah the
cable management
is atrocious literally literally it's
like it's a laptop that's sitting
um that's like hooked up on a like on a
foldable chair
that's like that's like connected with
wide internet that's just running in the
middle of the floor
that's that's it that's that's trash
tastes awesome it is jank is fun
that's because we can't afford more
space right now so
it's like the most jank it's mostly for
us enough of us complaining about
our problems i guess uh everything
should hopefully
be better we don't know because we
haven't moved yet but we're hoping that
everything goes really smoothly
offset i want to shout out to the
denny's guy you're the real g
the denny's guy is always there for us
we've talked before about
boss man's always waiting for us yeah
we've talked before about how ev
every every time four trash chase
recording we have lunch at denny's
and we've gone there so often that
there's a guy at denny's who knows the
exact
time we're coming in on the exact day
and he
he he knows he knows what we want we
ordered the same thing every time he
knows how many people as well
i've not i've not met a boss man in
japan
and yeah i hadn't met a boss man in
japan until i met that guy
you're a boss man he's real boss man
he's the man i love i love her because
like sometimes we would come into the
danny's
yeah and he would just the moment he
sees us he's like hey oh okay
it's like four right yeah i got you i
got you i've got it reserved for you
don't worry you're going to miss the
milf bar that's also
like next door as well so we we just we
discovered we discovered a bar
a restaurant just it's it's just it's
just a woman yeah it's just
it's just a restaurant that's just run
by attractive older japanese
single mills and i remember i remember
conor first going into there and
it's kind of like and he had an
awakening
because it's a new bar and then we
almost we came back almost every week
for a while
the land of milk and honey it's right
around the corner
what a beautiful bar yeah i'm going to
miss this area as well
like it's like you know i didn't have
much expectations for this area
obviously we're not because
yeah but like you know we've come so
after a year we've come to
you know appreciate the small things you
know we could say we're inside them all
right it's whatever
sure we can say we're inside yeah sure
okay
yeah i mean i don't think it matters now
we're not we're not we're not there
anymore
yeah yeah we're good guys again we're
not there anymore so we we were inside
dumber but not anymore
commuting was a pain in the ass exactly
again everything was on a budget side to
my eyes
outside of tokyo it's like an hour it's
like an hour away from tokyo it's
immediately cheap just
just close enough that it kind of feels
like it's in tokyo yeah
kind of like being in zone four zone
five in london right yeah it's like tell
your you know
love to be like yeah so the studio is at
uh heathrow airport just uh
it wasn't it wasn't that far it wasn't
that well heathrow apple's like an hour
of
power from central london yeah but tokyo
is a lot bigger as well though
i mean you can go from one end of tokyo
to yo to young another in an hour as
well so
i understand these references
[Laughter]
[Music]
i guess thank you for watching thank you
for watching season one yeah
you have much else to say really yeah i
hope you guys stick with us
all through season two look forward to
more fun epic
i mean there probably won't be a season
thing i don't think we plan on uh
upgrading from the new studios
yeah it'll be it'll be season two for a
while
season one is the test run yeah season
two is the the one that has like 500
episodes
okay don't don't think there's going to
be many new plot developments
yeah this is literally it this is like
season one was like the 54 episode pilot
season two is where the actual show
begins
yeah but uh yeah hopefully uh you guys
enjoy the new studio yeah
it's just like arthur does arthur have
seasons i don't know if arthur has
arthur
arthur oh you mean the the show the
cartoon
yeah does that have seasons does arthur
have seasons i feel like it's just
running
i don't know we're like we're gonna be
like arthur we're just never gonna stop
aaron
every single week i've never heard of
anyone being like uh season 23 of arthur
was my favorite
does arthur have seasons can you google
it arthur doesn't have seasons it just
runs it just keeps going
i say it's more like come dine with me
right we're just gonna keep coming
and coming every week we come every week
guys trash days comes every week
guys now
we'll see you guys next time no we got a
shout out to the people we've got to
shout out the patrons
these lovely look at this look at these
patrons whom without we could not move
into a new studio and exactly
a better setup than we're than we do now
off screen
absolutely no it doesn't [ __ ] off
season 22 season 22 it's basically one
season
one long season 22. i don't even i can't
tell but hey if you like arthur season
22 then make sure to go over to our
patreon patreon.com
also follow us on twitter send us your
memes on the subreddit and if you don't
have faces uh listen to us on spotify
and also go subscribe to after dark
there's gonna be a lot more content
there hopefully
hopefully hopefully starting very soon
though
yeah bye bye old studio buy old studio
i mean we're taking most of this with us
i mean i'm i'm taking vs with me
what were you going to say going for i
brutally interrupted you i have no idea
fantastic all right see you guys in the
new studio guys
next like our slowest outro ever what
the [ __ ] is that
[Music]
you